Chat, ich habe gerade gemerkt, dass mein Klopapier alle ist.
Radiant Tracer, Nero und Dr. PrunupX.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Extremely abog.
Ihr wisst schon Bescheid.
Um den Satz zu vollenden.
Mir ist aufgefallen, dass mein Klopapier alles ist.
Aber, glücklicherweise, habe ich noch die Hälfte von meinem Corona-Klopapier-Stapel, den ich bestellt habe.
Ich habe ja damals zu Corona so eine Palette Klopapier bestellt.
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung was, das waren 28 Stück oder so.
Und die Hälfte ist noch da, weil ich benutze die immer nur, wenn irgendwas alles ist.
Also musste ich nur, deswegen hat es auch ein paar Minuten länger gedauert, bis ich wieder am Rechner war, als geplant.
Ich musste rüber ins Schlafzimmer und so eine neue...
So, so ein neues Pack holen.
Ja, alles, alles, komplett.
Ich weiß noch, wie sich die Leute damals aufgeregt haben, ey.
Das werde ich bis heute nicht checken, ne.
Die Leute haben damals kein Klopapier gekriegt, haben sich aufgeregt.
Aber wenn du dir Klopapier woanders gekauft hast, haben sie sich auch aufgeregt.
Ja, sie haben sich alle aufgeregt.
Die stehen im Schlafzimmer, ja.
Neben einem Kleiderschrank.
Da hat man so einen großen Kleiderschrank stehen.
Daneben ist ein Tisch und unter dem Tisch sind die...
Die restlichen Klopapier.
Also nicht Rollen, sondern halt diese Packen mit den Rollen drin gestapelt.
Wir müssen jetzt mal kurz Arch-Package-Update machen.
Weil, by the way, ich use Arch und deswegen Mehl.
Bestimmt.
Brauche ich sehr selten.
Ging doch nicht.
Haben wir ausprobiert, ging doch nicht.
Lohnt es sich beruflich...
Was lohnt es sich beruflich in Richtung Frankfurt zu orientieren?
Du meinst Drogenabhängigkeit?
Am Hauptbahnhof oder was?
Wobei man sagen muss, es sind erstaunlich wenige Drogenabhängigen am Hauptbahnhof in letzter Zeit.
Das Ganze wurde eher ersetzt mittlerweile.
Durch...
Mal sagen, zum größten Teil Afrikaner.
Ich weiß nicht, was die da machen, aber die gammeln den ganzen Tag ab.
Aber es sind nicht mehr die alten 0815 Drogenabhängigen, die man so von früher kennt.
Ich weiß nicht, die sind jetzt eher so Nidderstraße und sowas in der Richtung.
Also Leute, falls ihr irgendwann mal...
Ich weiß, ich habe es schon ein paar Mal erzählt.
Aber falls ihr irgendwann mal in Frankfurt und Umgebung rum...
Ach, wo bin ich wieder im Main?
Frankfurt und Umgebung rumlauft, macht mal einen Umweg hier drum.
Ihr kommt nämlich direkt hier aus dem Hauptbahnhof raus.
Und gerade hier Nidderstraße, Nidderstraße hoch, diese Seitenstraßen hier.
Diese Seitenstraßen hier.
Da sammelt sich echt alles.
Und da stinkt es übertrieben in diesen Straßen.
Weil den ganzen Tag Leute auf die Gast pissen.
Also gerade Nidderstraße und hier so die Ecke, das ist wirklich so ganz, ganz abartig.
Macht da einen Bogen drum, Leute.
Falls ihr mal in Frankfurt seid.
8 Kill, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Gibt es eine Backstory dazu?
Warum eine ungefähre Standard?
Warum ist das immer in Gewässern?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Vielleicht ist das irgendwas, eine Anonymisierungsmaßnahme von Chrome?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Wo ist das?
Ich bin jetzt da.
Ich bin da.
Also auf geht's, Leute.
Stand up.
Oder ist heute vielleicht sogar Chat.
Vielleicht ist heute sogar Sprint-Retrospektive.
Wenn ich mir das recht überlege.
Sprint-Retrospektive.
Sprint-Planung.
Sprint-Review.
Sure-Fix.
Und, ähm, Refinement.
Machen wir alles in einem jetzt.
Bisschen Hyper-Agile.
Moin, Michael.
Fünf Spieljahren.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Hyper-Subscriber.
Du bist...
Wo habe ich denn das?
Subscriber.
Nee.
Ähm.
Muss ich kurz durchlesen, ja.
Man kann nicht genug Scrum haben.
Mein, mein persönliche, meine persönliche Planung ist ja, wir machen jetzt Mikro-Scrubs.
Das heißt, wir sprinten weniger, als das wir planen zu sprinten.
Versteht ihr?
Also, also wir machen, wir machen Planning.
Und dann sprinten wir einen halben Tag.
Und dann...
Einen halben Tag.
Einen halben Tag ist noch nicht agil genug.
Viertel Stunde.
Als DevOps-Plattform-Engineer oder so mit einem Tag vor Ort.
Ja, klar.
Also gerade Frankfurt ist, was IT-Jobs angeht, richtig gut.
Ja.
Vielleicht, wenn du schon ein paar Jahre Berufserfahrung hast, natürlich noch begehrter alles.
Hab gehört, der, der reine, so der, der, der, der Anfänger-Einsteiger-Junior-Markt ist gerade wohl so ein bisschen wild, wie man das, wobei, wobei heute sagt man ja, das sagt man bestimmt auch schon gar nicht mehr.
He, he, he.
Am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof ist es so, ja.
Ja, hat sich doch mein Agile-Training gelohnt.
Das kann man auch nicht verstehen, weil es jeder anders macht.
Und die Leute, die am meisten über Agile...
Und Zeug drumherum reden, die haben wahrscheinlich immer noch am wenigsten Plan von, also wie man tatsächlich dann auch mal was umsetzt.
Ich muss sagen, in einem Projekt, wo ich auf der Arbeit dabei bin, da sind wir auch agil unterwegs, wie man das so schön immer nennt.
Das ist natürlich auch wieder so ein bisschen, generell ist das in vielen Unternehmen so ein bisschen Augenwischerei, weil eigentlich klappt das nur wirklich gut, wenn die ganzen Sachen drumherum dazu passen, ja.
Wenn man, wenn man in irgendeinem Laden ist, der super...
Ähm, langsam, Workflow-orientiert, konservativ, teilweise mit ganz alten Sachen am Start ist und dann, dann soll auf einmal ganz furchtbar agil, aber nur in dieser einen Sache furchtbar agil sein, dann klappt das meistens nicht, weil man ist ja nicht losgelöst von allem anderen, ja.
Was bringt's, wenn man so tut, als ist man super krass agil und sprint...
Planning macht, Retrospektiven macht, Refinements macht, äh, was es da nicht auch alles gibt.
Aber dann, sobald's drauf ankommt, äh, hängt man von irgendeinem anderen Team ab, was nicht in diesem Projekt dabei ist und die dann offiziell nicht agil sind.
Und dann braucht man drei Wochen mit, mit Workflow und fünffachem Durchschlag, ja.
Hast du vor, Chrome noch...
Ich werd Chrome so lange verwenden, bis ich feststelle, also ich benutze, ich benutze Chrome...
Chrome, Chromium und, wobei ich mir vorstellen könnte, vielleicht wird das sogar hier rausgepatcht, ich weiß nicht, ich benutze, aber dann gibt's keine neuen Extensions, ja.
Also ich benutze Chrome, Chromium, Firefox, sollte mir Chrome in irgendeiner Weise auf den Sack gehen, machen wir das hier überhaupt noch auf, mit ihrem Manifest-Zeug, dann ist das ganz einfach, dann werde ich einfach wieder exklusiv Firefox verwenden.
Unter Linux verwende ich exklusiv, äh, bis auf ganz wenige Ausnahmen Firefox.
Unter Windows ist tatsächlich hauptsächlich Chrome.
Das hat sich in den letzten Jahren übereingeschliffen.
Ich habe aber auch überhaupt keine Probleme damit, einfach Firefox zu verwenden wieder.
Ich persönlich mag ja Firefox eh mehr.
Leider, das ist echt so ein Ding, Firefox hätte echt so das, das, das Potenzial, jetzt vielleicht nicht der weltweit verbreitetste Browser zu sein, aber die, die Leute, die sich für Firefox interessieren, happy zu machen, so.
Und das machen sie irgendwie in den letzten, letzten Jahren immer weniger.
Ja gut, wahrscheinlich, weil sie Geld verdienen müssen, ja.
Firefox ist, du meinst, weil Teile von Firefox in Rust gerittet, geritet sind, ja, dann, das stimmt, da habe ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht.
Das ist ja quasi Powered by Rust.
Ups, was jetzt?
Hat sich das gerade geupdatet?
Mozilla hat seinen Arsch, haben sie?
Ich, ich weiß, dass Mozilla zum größten Teil halt von Google Werbeeinnahmen irgendwie abhängt.
Aber warum?
Okay, ich glaube, ach ja, das ist hier, Toolbox hat sich aktualisiert.
Okay, nice, Updates durch, Ausrufezeichen OS, ich glaube, wir haben Ausrufezeichen Linux, haben wir, in Command, aber ich kann dir sagen, was das ist, weil ich habe kein Problem, das, damit, das oft genug zu erzählen, weil ich use Arch, by the way.
Und das kann man nicht oft genug sagen.
Ausrufezeichen Linux, genau.
Wie, keine Storys?
Wir verwenden hier keine Storys, wir haben nur Epic Tasks.
Und auch nur bis zur Vergangenheit.
Fünf T-Shirt-Größen.
Das ist jetzt nicht ausgedacht gewesen.
Da sieht man aber, die drehen echt alle ein bisschen frei, wenn es um solche Sachen geht.
Hat jemand auch schon mal die Ehre gehabt, in einem Unternehmen zu arbeiten, dass die Zeitaufwände in T-Shirt-Größen gemessen hat?
Kennt das jemand?
Im Prinzip ist das genau das Gleiche, wie man gibt die Zeit direkt an, nur dass es irgendwie, dass sich irgendjemand gedacht hat, ja, das ist gar nicht so selten.
Ja.
Nur, dass sich irgendjemand gedacht hat, das klingt griffiger.
Da gibt es dann halt sowas, weißt du, normalerweise, in Deutschland messen wir das in Fußballfeldern, normalerweise.
Ja, S-Task, XXL-Task ist sowas ähnliches, wie, wie, genau, sowas in der Richtung.
How Mozilla Ruined Firefox, okay.
Das da?
Okay, das gucken wir uns gleich an.
Das ist eben mein Plan für heute.
Dass wir uns, äh, dass wir ein bisschen schwätzen und Videos angucken.
Weil heute ist kein MMO-Kreiselgrind.
Hab ich gedacht, ich mach mal den Stream an.
Bei uns haben sie wieder zurückgewechselt.
Ein Storypoint, ein Tag.
Leute, also ich bin ja schon der Meinung, dass diese ganze PT-Geschichte teilweise fragwürdig ist, was da geschätzt wird.
Aber ich get es ja schon irgendwie in gewisser Weise, dass man so eine grobe Orientierung haben will.
Wie lang dauert was?
Ja, das, das verstehe ich ja schon.
Und, dass wir die Zeitangaben in Tage machen.
Es ist irgendwie, ich mein, das Problem ist, bei Zeitangaben in Tagen, es gibt viele Sachen, die kannst du überhaupt nicht richtig schätzen, ja.
Und da kommen dann immer so Antworten wie, ja, dann, dann, dann schätze doch mal, wenn alles möglichst optimal läuft.
Aber du weißt ja schon, es läuft nicht alles optimal.
Außerdem ist es schwierig, Sachen zu schätzen, wenn gewisse Dinger noch nicht definiert sind, unbekannt, um was es eigentlich geht.
Ja, und allgemein ist das, ist das allgemein, also es ist allgemein schwierig, gerade wenn es Interaktion zwischen verschiedenen Themen gibt.
Und dann, wenn es so ein Problem hat, deswegen musst du da eigentlich immer ein bisschen mehr draufhauen.
Am Ende kommt es trotzdem nicht hin.
Also Planungen sind eigentlich dazu verdammt zu scheitern.
Deswegen ist es auch wichtig, und ich glaube, das habe ich so noch nie im Stream gesagt, dass man einen ordentlichen Projektleiter oder Projektmanager oder wie auch immer hat.
Weil das ist, das ist der Job von solchen Leuten, das quasi on the fly alles schön zu updaten.
Und auf den aktuellen Stand zu bringen, sodass es dann doch wieder am Ende hinhaut.
Ja, alles grob überschlagen und dann verdoppeln, ja, so ungefähr.
Das, da kommt ja immer so, ja, überleg dir halt mal, wie lange es im optimalsten Fall brauchen würde, wenn dich keiner dabei unterbricht.
Das ist auch so ein, so ein Ding, weil eine Sache, die mir bei Zeitplanung immer extrem auf den Keks geht, ist,
dass komplett außer Acht gelassen wird, dass die Gehirnkapazität bekräftigt.
Ich glaube, man versteht nicht, wie ich das meine, aber ich versuche das mal zu erklären.
Also, stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt, übertrieben gesagt, ihr seid in drei Projekten und habt gerade 30 offene Tickets oder so, ja.
Das kann sich unterschiedlich zusammensetzen, ja, noch in unterschiedlichen Ticketsystemen am besten, ja.
Super Agile in Jira, das eine, und das andere noch in, Leute, was ist, was ist das oldschooligste Ticketsystem, was euch so eintrifft?
Ja, das andere noch in, Leute, was ist, was ist das oldschooligste Ticketsystem, was euch so eintrifft?
Ja, das andere noch in, Leute, was ist das oldschooligste Ticketsystem, was euch so eintrifft?
OCRS, das habe ich noch nie benutzt
Lotus Notes, ja, Lotus Notes ist kein Ticketsystem
Lotus Notes ist
eine Datenbank mit einem schlechten Mailsystem
Excel, okay, Excel
ja, also
was immer aus, was immer
nicht im Blick behalten wird oder irgendwie
bei diesen ganzen Planungen immer runter
Red, oh Gott
Redmine, hör mir bloß auf
Alter, wenn ich das höre
ich bin irgendwie viel zu weit
Redmine
Alter
gibt es das überhaupt noch?
Das ist ja nicht wirklich so ein Ticketsystem
das ist eher so ein Projektmanagement
System
Guckt euch die Fette
Gibt es das irgendwie auf Github?
Shit, das wird immer noch geumtated
Das ist eine Ruby on Rails
Anwendung
Zumindest, um das jetzt mal
fertig zu sagen, diesen Satz
Wird immer vergessen, dass deine
Gierenkapazitäten begrenzt sind, ja, verschiedene
Ticketsysteme, drei verschiedene Projekte
30 verschiedene Tickets
Du kannst nur bis zu einem
gewissen Punkt
von einem Thema zum anderen Thema springen
und direkt weitermachen
Irgendwann hört es einfach auf, was du so im Arbeitsspeicher
halten kannst im Kopf
Und bei mir ist das mittlerweile, ich bin fast 40
Bei mir ist das eigentlich mittlerweile genau
ein Thema, auf das ich mich konzentrieren kann
Weiß nicht, wie das bei euch aussieht
Aber so richtig konzentrieren kann ich mich
eigentlich nur auf ein Thema
Sobald ich was anderes machen muss, zwischendurch
unterbrochen werde, wie auch immer
Brauche ich erstmal eine ganze Weile, bis ich mir
überlegt habe, okay, was will der jetzt eigentlich
von mir, was war da jetzt nochmal, was haben wir
da zuletzt gemacht
Vielleicht noch irgendwie was nachgucken
Sonst was, und das dauert
Und das wird komplett außer Acht gelassen
Und wenn du vier, fünf verschiedene Sachen am Tag
machen musst, die nichts mehr miteinander zu tun haben
Dann geht, und das ist jetzt, das ist keine
Übertreibung, da geht
fast die Hälfte deiner Arbeitszeit
drauf
Dich wieder reinzudenken und zu überlegen
Und auch nochmal zu gucken
dass du jetzt kein Mist machst
Die Hälfte der Zeit, das ist nicht unrealistisch
Und das wird bei solchen Planungssachen immer komplett außen vor gelassen
So ist es ein bisschen so wie Context Switch
bei einem Thread
Irgendwann macht, hört es auf, wo es Sinn macht
zu parallelisieren
Weil das, weil das mehr schadet, als dass es was bringt
Ein schönes Beispiel habe ich mal gehört in irgendeinem Konferenztalk
Wo es um das Thema Projektmanagement ging
Und dass da oftmals komplett an der Realität geplant wird
Und zwar, da hat gesagt
Im Projektmanagement wird immer mit PT geplant
Und man denkt, wenn man mehr Leute einplant für das Projekt
Dann geht das dann...
Also quasi, eine Person braucht zwei Tage
Zwei Personen brauchen einen Tag
Und ich habe gesagt
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die auf die Idee kommen
weil überall anders in der Realität sieht das anders aus
Und da hat man gesagt
Ist das wirklichüssig?
hat er das beispiel gebracht wir wollten ein kind das kind braucht neun monate
was ist denn aber wenn ihr jetzt zwei frauen habt braucht es dann plus 4,5
monate es gibt halt sachen die lassen sich
schlecht splitten neun frauen neun frauen kind in einem monat easy ja da
sieht man halt das was im projektmanagement gemacht wird ist nicht
immer so realistisch ja du fährst mit zwei autos falls doppelt so schnell geht
ja ich nehme auch morgens immer zwei züge dass ich pünktlich ankomme
was braucht man eigentlich ein docker wenn du bei aliexpress was bestellst auf
container schiff ich gehe aber davon aus du möchtest eine etwas umfassendere
antwort haben was das thema linux container angeht oder ja das ist wichtig
out of out of the box und du brauchst eben eine richtige
machenweise
mentalität hands-on nichtmacher sorry wo kommen wir denn da hin wenn man das
deutsch nennt hands-on mentalität brauchst du es könnte aber auch sein
dass die verspätung sich aufhebt das halt die frage in der regel könnte man
sagen wenn du nicht weißt für was man docker braucht ist die chance eigentlich
relativ hoch dass du es nicht brauchst das ist natürlich eine antwort die die
beißt sich so ein bisschen in schwanz weil
receiving also deutlicher s Einheimler meinen glaube ich besonders
hin bemerkenswert par favorit
verständnis och
denial
docker ist das was jeder kennt letztendlich ist portman in der regel auch fast immer so zu 90
prozent zumindest so job in replacement aber docker bleibt nach wie vor dass das tool was
die meisten leute kennen also server mit docker ausrollen wenn wir jetzt neu ja ohne ohne kontext
ist das natürlich blöd weil doch also ursprünglich ich sag dir mal den ursprünglichen anwendungszweck
für docker und das ist das wofür es meiner meinung nach auch fast schon hat er selbst
vielleicht ein bisschen zu übertrieben nicht der einzige ein der beste einsatzzweck ist aber der
beste bleiben dabei der beste einsatzzweck ist nicht so der einzige man kann durchaus auch wenn
man jetzt nur eine eine vm hatten drei anwendungen laufen lassen will und alle dependencies und damit
docker starten macht schon sind aber ich kann dir sagen der ursprüngliche anwendungszweck für docker
ist das problem
zu lösen dass entwickler haben wenn sie software programmieren und zwar das problem dass sie was
ausprobieren bei sich auf der entwickler kiste und es dann auf anderen entwickler kisten nicht
mal funktioniert oder auch auf live system nicht funktioniert das ist so eigentlich eines der
ursprünglichen gedanken hinter docker so und letztendlich muss man sich früher oder später
da auch mit
linux container ein bisschen auseinandersetzen weil docker ist ja nicht gleich container docker
ist im endeffekt nur ein frontend eigentlich eigentlich zum größten teil hauptsächlich
den cli tool für container handling unter linux da gibt es noch deutlich mehr als docker aber
docker ist so eines der ersten und bekanntesten dies da gibt und mit docker
also wie docker das gelöst hat ist docker ein relativ einfaches bildsystem eingebaut ich bin zwar bildsystem mit dem
duh images erstellen kannst und dieses image enthält alles was deine anwendung braucht um
zu laufen hardcoded quasi das wird alles in den image gebaut und dieses image kann man dann
nehmen und auf dem anderen rechner wieder starten mit docker oder hat man exakt das was
du auf der entwickler kiste hat ist also ausprobiert hast also als du das image gebaut hast nicht fast grâceà sein lokal auf das Auto mit den rentenetsch Jeremiah 8 Ger hetze der, was sie ausprobiert hat.
image gebaut dass nicht was sind lokal auf dem Internet, für kostenuiеров spicca im fairpad die導 Jupiter mit doch hat man exakt das was, was du auf seiner entwickler kiste als ausprobiert meter ist.ый 내려ger war zUnalsller soll ein pairеждom.
du das Image gebaut hast, nicht was du lokal auf deiner Entwicklerkiste installiert hast.
Dafür war Docker ursprünglich mal, oder ich weiß nicht, ich kann es euch jetzt nicht
sagen, ich habe nicht mit dem Docker-Erfinder gesprochen, aber eines der ursprünglichen
Gedanken hinter Docker, baust quasi Self-Contained-Application-Images im Endeffekt, die so überall laufen, wo es
eine Container-Runtime gibt.
Muss übrigens nicht Docker sein, du kannst mit Docker Images bauen, die du auch mit anderen
Container-Runtimes laufen lassen kannst, zum Beispiel Kubernetes, das ist glaube ich
so der hauptsächliche Fall.
Image wird gebaut mit Docker, laufen gelassen, letztendlich in Produktion wird es auf Kubernetes.
Deswegen sind es auch keine Docker-Container, das ist streng genommen falsch.
Das sind alles Linux-Container und im Speziellen die ganze Image-Verwaltung drumherum, das
sind OCI-Container.
Open Container, für was steht OCI?
Open Container Initiative.
Ja gut, das stimmt schon, aber du kannst mit Docker keinen Server bereitstellen in dem
Sinn.
Du brauchst immer noch irgendwas, wo deine Container-Runtime draufläuft.
Was du machen kannst, ist, du kannst natürlich, das ist wahrscheinlich das, was du meinst,
du kannst natürlich dein Server-Setup vereinfachen, weil du im Endeffekt nur einen Server brauchst
mit einer Container-Runtime drauf und dann sagst du hier Container-Runtime-Image starten
und gut ist und alles, was die Anwendung braucht, ist halt mit drin.
Kannst auch zentral die Sachen updaten, neue Versionen besser deployen, macht schon Sinn,
aber sag mal.
Einer der ursprünglichen Gedanken in der Docker ist das, was ich gesagt habe.
Warum dein Ausbilder das jetzt von dir wissen will, weiß ich nicht.
Was lernst du denn?
Wenn du Anwendungsentwickler lernst, vielleicht was anderes als System, aber das musst du
ihm mal fragen, so wie, was will er eigentlich genau von dir?
Wie, System-Integrator eigentlich?
So steht das in Frage?
Dann mach das, dann mach das Getting Started, das Docker Getting Started und guck dir mal an.
Okay.
Ich habe noch ein paar YouTube-Videos zu an.
Ne, ne, wir gucken das jetzt.
Okay.
Also, ich weiß nicht, ob das Video was taugt.
Empfehlung vom Chat, das angeblich Firefox jetzt auch sagt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich bin auch der Meinung, Firefox hat das ein bisschen verkackt.
Ja, die sind im Mainstream erwartungsgemäß abgeschissen gegen Google.
Aber die haben sich jetzt auch nicht gerade viel Mühe gegeben, so ihre, wie könnte man
das nennen, so Kern-User-Base, nämlich technisch interessierte, will nicht sagen Bastler, aber
technisch interessierte Power-User, nennen wir es mal, weiterhin abzuholen.
Ja, die haben von...
Ja, die haben von ein paar Jahren, jetzt nicht so was wie Manifest V3, aber die ist Firefox Chromium-based.
Die Frage stelle ich dir jetzt, als Physi im zweiten Ausbildungsjahr, ist Firefox Chromium-based?
Das ist was, was man als Fachinformatiker Systemintegration beantworten können sollte im zweiten Jahr.
Sollte nicht.
Das lasse ich nicht gelten.
Ist er nicht oder ist er?
Ist jetzt wild gegoogelt erst mal.
Ist nicht.
Gut.
Stimmt.
Das ist korrekt.
Glück gehabt, bist zur Zwischenprüfung angemeldet.
Ja, dass sie ein bisschen die Power-User auch verloren haben, mit ihrem komischen Zeug, was
sie da auf Android getrieben haben, mit, also die haben ja dann irgendwie teilweise zwei,
drei verschiedene Firefox-Versionen gehabt, dann haben sie komische Bookmark-Services reingebaut,
wieder rausgebaut.
Irgendwelche, was weiß ich, komische VPN-Services reingebaut, wieder rausgebaut, ganz komische
Dinge.
Und dann haben sie vor ein paar Jahren was getrieben, dass sie ihre alte Plugin-API abgeschaltet
haben, was damals dazu geführt hatte, dass NoScript nicht mehr funktioniert hat.
Und NoScript war für mich so eines der Killer-Adhons schlechthin für Firefox.
Das war auch die Zeit, wo ich gesagt habe, okay, wenn NoScript nicht mehr funktioniert,
dann kann ich auch Chrome nehmen.
Ja, also die haben so ein bisschen ihre Kern-User-Base, so ein bisschen.
camp is so ein bisschen nicht so zufrieden stellen können die letzten Jahre über.
Ist zumindest mein Eindruck bei Firefox.
Wie gesagt es war mit dem Chrome-Release zu erwarten, dass Firefox abkackt, aber Firefox
hat ja halt versucht, weiter oben hin eben mitzuspielen, anstatt auf die Kern-User-Base
zu setzen.
Ist zumindest mein Eindruck der Sache.
Es ist nicht, dass Firefox schlecht ist.
Für mich ist Firefox immer noch insgesamt der beste Browser
im Punkto, wie sicher man sich sein kann,
dass der morgen auch noch ordentlich funktioniert
und nicht irgendein Shit passiert.
So wie bei Chrome mit Manifest V3 und sowas.
Also insgesamt finde ich eine Welt mit Firefox
deutlich besser als eine ohne.
Mir wäre es aber ganz recht, wenn Firefox einfach sagen würde,
ey, scheiß drauf, sollen sie halt alle Chrome verwenden,
aber wir machen halt einen richtig guten Browser
für Power-User.
Was sagst du zu Betafox, GS?
Das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Wir wissen alle, dass Mosaik, wenn schon,
denn schon der beste Browser ist.
Weil es war der erste Browser.
Logischerweise ist der erste Browser auch der beste Browser.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns das Video an.
Das war schon wenig.
Wer nutzt Vivaldi?
Ich fand Vivaldi, als es gelauncht ist, echt cool.
Aber ich habe...
Kein Anwendungszweck für...
Vivaldi ist quasi der Opera,
Opera 2.0, wenn man es so will,
von den...
von den alten, ehemaligen Opera-Entwicklern.
Oder von einem zumindest.
Wie viele da noch dabei sind, weiß ich nicht.
Ich brauche die ganzen Sachen, die da eingebaut sind, aber nicht.
Deswegen
fand ich es sehr cool am Anfang.
Aber ich habe es mittlerweile, glaube ich, noch nicht mal mehr...
Nee, nicht mal mehr installiert.
Und...
SatchelSilver, dankeschön für den Sub.
Pog.
Nutzt wer eigentlich Opera?
Also ich nicht.
Und ich würde es auch keinem raten,
einen chinesischen Browser zu verwenden.
Opera wollte mich mal sponsoren.
Also, Sponsoren ist das falsche Wort.
Opera wollte mal ein Placement-Video kaufen.
Und...
Das muss man ihnen zugutehalten.
Ich habe die gefragt, ob ich denn den Browser wirklich benutzen muss.
Dafür.
Ja, die wollten halt, dass ich ein Video mache und halt erzähle,
was mir daran gefällt und sonst wie.
Und ich habe ihnen halt gesagt, ich...
Ich möchte Opera...
Ich benutze Opera nicht und...
Ich möchte Opera auch nicht benutzen.
Ich kann aber was vorlesen, was ihr wollt.
Und da haben die gesagt,
das muss man ihnen echt zugutehalten.
Die wollen nur Leute, die begeistert sind für ihre Produkte.
Ja, okay.
Im Gegensatz zu NordVPN.
NordVPN war das vollkommen egal.
Bis sie gesehen haben, dass ich ein Video gemacht habe, mal...
Zum Thema VPN, wo unter anderem NordVPN auch nicht so gut weggekommen ist.
Dann wollten sie auf einmal nicht mehr.
Da haben sie zu mir gesagt, ja, ist ja schön, dass wir uns einig sind, aber...
Sie müssen erst dieses Video hier löschen.
Da habe ich gesagt, nö, mache ich nicht.
Und dann habe ich nichts mehr von denen gehört.
Ich war noch nie in einer Wüste.
Wer weiß, was passiert.
Was ich bei Opera hätte sagen müssen.
Okay, jetzt lasst uns aber das Video gucken.
Raid Shadow Legends...
Habe ich bisher mich immer davor gedrückt, das zu machen.
Auch denen ist es auch fast egal, ob du das selbst magst oder nicht.
Hauptsache, du sagst,
das Richtige.
Da hatte ich aber bisher keinen Bock.
Was haben wir hier übrigens?
Was ist denn hier gerade für Weeb-Content am Start?
Ist das...
Ist das Firefox-Chan und...
Chrome...
Sun, oder was?
Oder...
Das ist der meistkommene Narrativ, den du da hörst.
Leider für sie hat Google Chrome nur ihren Lunch gegessen.
Weil Google Chrome ist jetzt der weltweit populärste Webbrowser mit 65% Marketschärfung.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das die ganze Geschichte ist.
Weil Mozilla, die Organisation hinter dem Firefox,
immer wieder schlechte Entscheidungen nach schlechten Entscheidungen über die Jahre gemacht hat.
Leute, ich habe, wo wir gerade beim Thema Weeb sind,
ich habe ja in letzter Zeit vermehrt ein paar Animes geschaut,
gerade weil mir die traditionellen Streaming-Services mit 1000 Abos so auf den Keks gehen
und man Animes relativ Grauzonen-mäßig easy streamen kann,
ohne 50 Accounts.
Und irgendwie bin ich etwas verstört.
Ich habe...
Chainsaw-Man geguckt.
Und...
Ich weiß echt nicht, was ich davon halten soll.
Die erste Hälfte besteht daraus, dass er laufend erzählt, dass er Boobs touchen will.
Das ist irgendwie sehr weird.
Sehr weird gewesen, keine Ahnung.
Auf jeden Fall kein familyfreundlicher Content, ja.
Und über die Jahre hat Mozilla's Hypocrisy,
ihre Verleumdung für ihre Benutzer,
und ihre aktivistischen Bemühungen, Firefox nur schlechter zu machen, anstatt besser zu machen,
Ja, das sehe ich auch so.
Die haben tatsächlich hart daran gearbeitet, dass Firefox sich gefühlt, gefühlt, ja,
ich gehe davon aus, dass unter der Haube sich sehr viel modernisiert und verbessert,
dass sich Firefox gefühlt schlechter, als schlechterer Browser anfühlt,
für mich als, ich nenne uns mal Power-User, als früher.
Ja.
...
Was ist eigentlich Firefox klar?
Das habe ich bis heute nicht gecheckt.
Das ist irgendwie so,
äh,
eine Mobile Firefox App mit eingebautem VPN oder sowas.
Also, da haben sie, da haben sie mich echt so ein bisschen verloren, Mozilla, was das angeht.
Privacy.
Mozilla protects your privacy, Mozilla cares about your privacy, Mozilla gives you outstanding privacy by default.
Firefox doesn't like all of these creepy trackers that follow you around the Internet.
I'm sure you know that big companies like Facebook and Google collect all kinds of your personal data to sell to advertisers.
And at first glance, this sounds pretty good.
Of course I want a browser that cares about my privacy.
So you might think that Mozilla is going to protect you from these big evil companies like...
Sehr, sehr gutes Game.
...Google that wanna harvest...
Wahrscheinlich kennen es die meisten gar nicht, aber, also auf der PS2 war das, ich glaube, das war eines der letzten PS2 Games?
...ich da jetzt durcheinander gebracht, äh, gebracht habe.
Das sah damals nicht so gut aus, das ist irgendeine Art, Art, Artwork dahinter.
...your personal data.
Shadow of the Colossus, richtig, richtig gutes Game.
...I mean, they even ran this giant advertising campaign years ago.
...saying big...
...or auch kurz.
Mit, mit, ey, ohne Scheiß, ich muss es jetzt einfach mal sagen, es gibt in Remastered, das Game hat eines der besten Soundtracks überhaupt.
Musst ihr euch mal anhören, Shadow, äh, Shadow of the Colossus.
Und wenn ihr es nicht selbst spielen könnt, oder nicht wollt, dann guckt euch zumindest ein Let's Play an, wobei man sagen muss, ich glaube, Let's Play davon ist echt ziemlich lahm, weil das Spiel hat kaum Content.
Außer, glaube, das ist gar nicht...
...wie viel...
Ja gut, aber das kann man Mozilla in gewisser Weise noch nicht mal vorwerfen.
Ja, ich verstehe das, was er sagen will. Privacy hin, Privacy her und dann ist die Default Search Engine Google. Aber ich finde, das kann man Mozilla auch nur schwer vorwerfen. Erstens ist das, solange ich denken kann, in Firefox schon so gewesen. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es das von einmal auf den anderen geändert hat und alle auf einmal auf Google gelandet sind, obwohl sie nicht auf Google landen wollen.
Das ist das Erste. Und das Zweite ist, Firefox, die müssen ihre Entwickler...
Die müssen ihre Entwickler ja auch bezahlen, die müssen ja auch Geld verdienen. Genau, Gio, sehe ich genauso. Die müssen ja irgendwie Geld verdienen. Und das war von Anfang an die einfachste Möglichkeit. Zumal man die Suchmaschine easy ändern kann.
Das ist ein bisschen seltsam, weil Google eine der meisten Privacy-invasive Search Engines da draußen ist. Du würdest denken, dass sie...
Wieso, was ist mit Dr. Go? Ich verwende Dr. Go ganz gerne. Habe ich da irgendeinen Skandal verpasst, dass die sacken oder was jetzt auf einmal? Warte mal, bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben? Ah, hier, ich habe zu viel Zeug auf.
Dr. Go verkauft Daten. Wann ist denn das rausgekommen? Das habe ich ja schon komplett wieder verdrängt. Ist das wirklich so oder war das irgendwie nur mal ein Gerücht?
Ja, das ist aber im Prinzip schon seit es... Also fast seit Anfang an von Firefox.
Firefox.
Sie ist ja von Anfang an nicht mal Firefox, sondern ein Firebird-Browser.
Und von außen sieht es aus, als ob sie wirklich gegen Google sind. Aber in Wahrheit sind sie Mozilla's größter Kunde.
Ja, das ist nichts Neues.
Ich verstehe das nicht, weil wenn ich 500 Millionen Dollar von Google jedes Jahr bekommen würde, würde ich auch Profite über Menschen übernehmen.
Aber du kannst nicht...
Ich finde, diesen Punkt kann man Mozilla nicht wirklich vorwerfen.
Ich denke, das ist ein riesiger Deal, weil das ist eine Art gemeinsames Wissen. Viele Leute kennen das bereits.
Ja.
Das stimmt wohl.
Ja, ich signe auch in Chrome nicht mit meinem Google-Account.
Das stimmt schon.
Wobei man der Fairness halber sagen muss,
dass Faster sich in Grenzen hält.
Die haben sich jahrelang so ein Rennen geliefert.
In der Regel kann man sagen, Google hat mit V8 wirklich einen ganz großen Wurf gemacht.
Nicht umsonst, dass gefühlt das halbe Internet mittlerweile auf JavaScript...
auf der JavaScript-Engine von Chrome läuft.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so ein wahnsinnig großer Unterschied.
Mal ist Firefox, mal ist Chrome.
Ich würde sagen, in der Regel...
Wollen wir das mal ausprobieren?
Können wir machen.
Ja, wir können das ausprobieren.
Ach, das ist dieser Test.
Okay.
Liegt das am Ende auch nichts, wenn ich es durchlaufen lasse?
Da flutscht es.
Äh, okay.
Ich darf nicht vergessen, ich habe in beiden Browsern U-Block an.
Okay, Score.
29,1.
Okay, Firefox.
In Firefox...
habe ich auch U-Block an.
Und ansonsten...
glaube ich nichts.
Wir müssen jetzt echt gucken.
Nicht, dass ich noch mehr erinnere.
Lass mal gucken hier.
Managed Extensions.
Ja, ich habe wirklich nur U-Block.
Und in Chrome...
Ach, doch.
Nee, in Chrome habe ich, glaube ich, auch nur...
nur U-Block, ne?
Ja, FFZ ist hier nicht an.
Ja, okay.
Also im Prinzip...
das zeigt man ja.
Also 29,1.
Oder was war es bei Chrome?
Ich bewege jetzt die Maus absichtlich nicht.
Ich mache die auch mal raus hier.
29,1.
Ich bin gespannt, was Firefox hat.
24,6, guck mal.
Ja, sogar...
bei mir auf dem Rechner, hier in diesem Setup,
minimal schneller.
Bei Benchmarks ist es aber auch so ein Ding.
Wir wissen ja alle,
dass Hersteller gerne auf bekannte...
Ah, Moment. Langsamer. Langsamer.
Nicht 1 hatte. Okay. Chrome ist ein bisschen schneller.
Als Firefox.
Ja.
Aber Hersteller optimieren halt auch gerne auf Benchmarks.
Würde mich nicht wundern,
wenn das hier auch der Fall ist.
Aber es hält sich in Grenzen.
Es hält sich in Grenzen.
Also geschwindigkeitsmäßig ist beides fein.
Aber auch so ein Ding, was mich persönlich
an Firefox nervt, ist, dass sich
das Ding gefühlt mittlerweile irgendwie
vertabilisiert anfühlt.
Auch vom User Interface.
Not to mention that a lot of websites just work better
on Chrome than Firefox.
Because since most people use Chrome,
a lot of developers optimize for it.
Aber das ist selten.
Also mir fällt jetzt keine
Webseite ein, die ich in letzter Zeit aufmachen
wollte im Firefox,
die dann gesagt hat,
Firefox mag nicht.
Wie ist es bei Teams?
Teams hatte eine Weile mal Probleme
im Firefox, aber gegen...
gegen...
Skype habe ich nicht aufgemacht.
Mir fällt jetzt da kein Beispiel ein.
Die Firefox,
es ist traurig, aber wahr.
Und wenn Firefox schlechter ist als Chrome in all diesen
Aspekten, dann warum würdest du Firefox
über Chrome verwenden?
Wahrscheinlich deine Privatsphäre, oder?
Ich denke, viele Leute verwenden Firefox, weil sie
Privatsphäre interessieren.
Aber ich glaube, es ist nicht so wichtig,
wie du es machen kannst, als mit Chrome.
Zum Beispiel diese ganze Geschichte mit
TemperMonkey und was es da nicht noch alles gibt,
quasi zum Custom-JavaScript-Zeug
injecten.
Das gibt es teilweise auch
für Chrome, ist aber glaube ich bei weitem nicht
so umfangreich wie für Firefox.
Und dazu kommt, dass lange Zeit,
aber das hat sich die letzten Jahre
immer ganz stark gebessert,
die Developer-Tools
in Firefox für Webseiten
besser waren.
Aber jetzt muss ich ehrlich
sagen, ich bin ja nicht hauptberuflicher
Webentwickler oder sowas, muss ich sagen,
jetzt erkenne ich kaum noch einen Unterschied zwischen Chrome
DevTools und Firefox DevTools.
Nutzt ihr Teams im Browser oder im Desktop eher
als Desktop-Anwendung?
Und sie machen eine Browser-Extension,
die hilft, Fake-Reviews online zu spotten.
Sieht aus wie Full-Write,
aber lasst uns ihre Privatsache prüfen.
Welche Art von Informationen sammeln sie über ihre User?
Und sie sagen, sie werden deine persönliche
Informationen verwenden, um dir
Content und Advertisements zu bieten.
Warte, ist Mizzola dagegen, persönliche Daten
für targette Ads zu verwenden?
Ja, okay, ich glaube, das haben wir jetzt verstanden.
Weil
was diese Browser-Extension über dich sammelt,
sammelt deine Online-Shopping-Historie,
deine Location, deine Browser-Info,
deine Search-Historie,
und sie tracken dich mit Cookies und Tracking-Pixels.
Oh, und sie teilen auch all diese
Informationen mit dritten-Party-Advertisement-Partnern.
Also, sie werden all deine persönlichen Daten
verwenden und dann einfach wo sie wollen.
Und Mizzola hat
dieses Unternehmen vor ein paar Monaten gekauft,
und sie sagen, sie wollen das direkt in Firefox integrieren.
Aber natürlich, wenn sie es
in Firefox einbauen, werden sie es
mehr über Privatsache respektieren, oder?
Also, ich verstehe den Punkt.
Das ist ja im Prinzip nur ein Punkt, den
er hier hat.
Verstehe ich schon. Aber ich habe ja gesagt,
es gibt ja durchaus auch noch,
ich habe mich in den letzten Minuten darüber ausgelassen,
noch mehr Punkte, warum man Firefox
verwenden kann.
Mal gucken, was da noch kommt.
Ja, das ist immer Kacke.
Ja.
Man darf auch mal nicht vergessen,
so einen Webbrowser zu entwickeln, das kostet auch Geld.
Und das ist sicherlich
nicht billig. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele
Entwickler im Firefox-Team sind, aber
sind bestimmt nicht wenig. Ich bin auch der Meinung,
dass sich Mozilla in den letzten Jahren
über, man hätte deutlich mehr auf
Firefox konzentrieren sollen.
Anstatt auf zig Sachen
drumherum. Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Aber umsonst
ist es trotzdem nicht.
100% owned by
Mizzola. The Mizzola Corporation
and Mizzola Technologies Corporation.
And unlike
the noble non-profit, these companies
are all about making that cheddar.
And make no mistake, Mizzola is
a big business. They like to present
themselves as the scrappy underdog,
but as of 2021, they
have over 1.1 billion dollars
in assets. So this
is a huge company. But wait a minute,
doesn't Mizzola also collect donations?
If they're making so much money, what do they
need donations for? On their website,
they say that they rely on donations.
That's not entirely true.
Donations only make up 1% of their revenue.
In 2021,
Ah ja, du kannst
auch so einen Twitch-Streamer donaten
und die meisten brauchen das Geld auch nicht
und trotzdem machen's Leute.
They receive 7 million dollars out of 600 million dollars in revenue.
War der Chrome Source Code nicht
sogar größer als der von Windows? Ja.
Ja.
Oh and by the way,
if you donate to Mizzola,
not a single cent of your donations go towards
Firefox. Maybe you want to
support your favorite browser
that tries to make the world better.
Also, ich weiß nicht, irgendwie
überzeugt's mich nicht so
richtig.
Lack of focus!
Okay, da kommt vielleicht jetzt noch was,
was ich auch so sehe.
Because their browser has barely improved
in years, they keep trying to throw out
random things like a new
Mizzola VPN. Ja,
das unterschreib ich.
Das sind auch so Dinger, also,
ich hab ja auch schon gesagt, die hätten sich in den letzten Jahren
mal ein bisschen mehr auf ihren Browser fokussieren sollen.
Und ich glaube gar nicht, dass
der Browser gar nicht improved, das stimmt ja
überhaupt nicht. Wenn man sich die ganzen
neuen Webstandards guckt,
alles geht bei Mozilla. Also, die haben da schon
viel Arbeit reingesteckt, aber
trotzdem fühlt er sich irgendwie
nicht mehr so nice an wie früher.
Also, ja.
Ich bin immer noch der Meinung,
die hätten sich auf Power-User konzentrieren sollen.
Or a password manager.
And most of these things outside of the browser
that they try are just total failures.
Moment, es gibt
sowas wie Killed by Mozilla?
Gibt's sowas auch tatsächlich?
Ah, nee, Killed by Google.
Ey, doch, Moment.
Killed by Mozilla?
Gibt's das da sowas?
Ja.
Ja, wie gesagt, das ist das, was
ich vorhin auch schon meinte.
Dann haben sie mal da irgendwie was eingebaut
mit VPN, irgendeinen
Reader-Service und
das hab ich auch nicht verstanden.
Da geb ich ihm recht. Ja.
Naja,
der Anreiz,
das zu
improven ist,
war,
dass Google
die Anreize
für ihre Browser
besser machen kann.
Naja,
der Anreiz,
das zu
improven ist,
war,
weil man ja möchte,
dass man nicht noch weniger User
bekommt, beziehungsweise mehr User
bekommt, weil Google
ist es ja nicht so, als bezahlen
die den 500 Millionen einfach
just for fun. Also, wenn Firefox
nur noch 5 User hat, bezahlt das Google bestimmt auch nicht.
Ja, das stimmt.
Da kann man sich echt fragen,
was treibt das Mozilla Management
eigentlich so die letzten Jahre?
Also, das,
das letzten Punkt versteh ich schon.
Ja.
Hehe.
Ja, so muss man. Das
wahren Hackermans machen das so.
Es gibt noch einen weiteren Grund, warum ich
Firefox mag. Erstens hab ich den Eindruck, dass Firefox
unter Linux besser funktioniert als
Chrome, deswegen verwende ich den auch.
Hauptsächlich.
Zum Beispiel so Sachen wie Sound
Ausgabe, funktioniert bei mir unter Firefox
vielleicht ist das an meiner speziellen
Kombination hier aus
Arch I3 in der
VM. Zumindest die Soundausgabe
ist bei mir in Firefox
weniger laggy
und
funktioniert ohne Puls-Audio.
Chrome hat einfach keine Soundausgabe
gehabt ohne Puls-Audio.
Und ich hab keinen Bock Puls-Audio zu installieren.
Oder, wobei Puls-Audio
verwendet man noch, was verwenden die coolen Leute
heute unter Linux?
Ich bin ALSA-Enjoyer, aber ALSA ist
die Schicht unten drunter. Puls-Audio
verwendet auch noch ALSA.
Pipewire haben die coolen Leute, ok.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Pipewire.
Früher war es nur Puls-Audio, aber ich hab gar nichts installiert
außer den ALSA-Treiber
und das reicht Firefox für die
Soundausgabe. Und
ein weiterer Punkt ist,
vielleicht ist das auch ein Image-Ding,
was Mozilla einfach nur gut hinbekommen hat.
Ich traue Firefox
mehr,
dass da
morgen nicht irgendein versteckter Bullshit
drin ist im Browser
oder irgendwas essenzielles abgeschaltet wird.
Traue ich Mozilla
mehr als Google?
Vielleicht ist das falsch, mag sein,
aber ich glaube, dass selbst
wenn Mozilla
morgen sagt,
wir stellen Firefox ein, Firefox
trotzdem weiterleben würde.
Deswegen ist es wichtig,
einen zweiten Browser neben Chrome zu haben.
Wenn hätten wir das nicht,
könnte Google
komplett machen, was sie wollen und wir hätten gar keine Alternative.
Ja, es gibt noch
ein paar andere Browser, es gibt nicht nur
Firefox und Chrome,
es gibt zum Beispiel, das ist auch Chrome,
es gibt zum Beispiel noch,
ich sag's ja nicht gerne, aber
Safari, der wird uns aber auch nicht retten.
Safari ist Webkit,
also quasi der Ur-Ur-Ur-Enkel
von, also
nee, nicht Enkel, Vater von dem, was
auch in Chrome ist, wenn ich's
jetzt nicht durcheinander bringe.
Also Plink in Chrome und
Webkit, war
irgendwann mal Webkit, glaube ich, bin mir nicht ganz
sicher aus dem Kopf.
Es gibt noch ein paar andere Sachen, es gibt auch noch,
also es sind nicht
die einzigen Browser, aber die einzig zwei
ernstzunehmenden Browser, Chrome und
Firefox, dann gibt es noch,
wie heißt dieser komische Browser
von Gnome,
der Default Gnome Browser, der kaum was
unterstützt, den gibt's auch noch.
Es gibt schon
noch welche,
aber ich glaube,
es ist schwierig,
irgendwas auf die Beine zu
stellen als Alternative heutzutage,
weil ihr müsst euch mal überlegen,
was für riesengroße,
komplexe Projekte
Webbrowser mittlerweile sind.
Webbrowser sind, und das ist keine Übertreibung,
also Browser sind heutzutage
komplexer als die Betriebssysteme
unten drunter. Deutlich komplexer.
Letzte Statistik, die ich mal irgendwo gesehen hab,
das ist aber schon ein paar Jahre her,
da war der
Chrome Source Code ungefähr
fünfmal mehr,
als der Windows Source Code.
Versus Linux kenn ich keinen Vergleich,
müsste man auch mal gucken,
das wurde damals verglichen, als es dieses komische
Windows Leak gab.
Linux dürfte wahrscheinlich
noch komplexer sein, weil in Linux
saumäßig viele verschiedene
Architekturen drin sind,
und ganz viele abgedrehte Sachen.
Aber schauen wir doch mal,
wie viele Line of Codes
hat denn der Firefox, ich will mir das Repo
jetzt nicht klonen, weil das dauert
eine halbe Stunde.
Also ich hatte mal eine gute Statistik,
Firefox, GitHub,
wo ist denn der Source Code von Firefox überhaupt?
Bei Mozilla
wahrscheinlich.
Ja, Chrome ist auf jeden Fall fetter als Windows.
Source Docs.
Wo finde ich denn das
Mozilla?
Hier, git clone Firefox.
Äh, wenn man das so möchte.
Wo gibt's denn das überhaupt?
It's managed in a
... ach du Scheiße.
Im Vergleich zu Chrome
ist das ja richtig kompliziert.
Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Chrome kannst du dir einfach git klonen und gut ist.
Aber das ist natürlich für den Arsch.
21 Millionen
Zeilen, ja.
Also Browser, also
Webbrowser dürften heutzutage
die komplexesten Anwendungen sein, die es
auf dieser Welt gibt.
Falls euch
was anderes einfällt, was noch komplexer ist,
sagt's mir. Aber mir fällt
nix ein.
Browser sind komplexer als Betriebssysteme
oder jegliche andere Software.
Zumal Browser ja quasi halbe
Betriebssysteme sind eigentlich.
Mittlerweile.
Du hast Grafikrendering,
du hast
unten drunter
Audio, Video, IO,
Netzwerk,
JavaScript Engine,
du hast in einem Browser
Browser ist quasi
eigenes Betriebssystem
in einem extra Fenster nochmal
unter Windows hier.
Aber so toll fand ich das Video jetzt nicht.
Aber den letzten Punkt
gebe ich ihm recht.
Lack of Focus ist schon ein bisschen
doof.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Things to know before switching to Linux.
Och nee, jetzt.
If all humans died,
when would the last light
go out?
Oh ja, tatsächlich.
Von wann?
Ende 2023.
Ja, haben sie es jetzt auch schon geschafft.
Ey gut, das weiß man nicht.
Das weiß man nicht.
Der Client, das ist
Closed Source, das weiß man nicht.
Server, kann man sich ungefähr
ableiten?
Es gibt ja
Atlas hat ja damals
seinen
Dark Server
Open Source
und das sind
Kann man das hier irgendwo sehen?
Komm.
Nicht so viel auf jeden Fall.
Ups.
Nicht so viel, also
mal zu vergleichen mit einem
Open Source MMO Backend.
Klonen wir das mal.
Alter, was ist da alles drin?
Ach, auf
Insights.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Code Frequency?
Was?
Gibt man da irgendwo was sinnvolles?
Gibt man das irgendwo im Webinterface?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Schauen wir mal.
So, ist ausgecheckt.
Also MMO Backend hat
Ja, wie zählt man denn jetzt
alle Zeilen in einem
Die Zeilen aller Dateien
in einem Verzeichnis?
Das ist
eine gute Frage.
Man könnte
Man könnte einen Find machen oder sowas.
Und dann
Ah, nice.
Was git
git ls files
Das wird wahrscheinlich
Ich glaube das funktioniert
nicht.
Weil das zu viele Dateien sind.
Aber wir können es mal ausprobieren.
Oh doch, funktioniert.
Guck mal.
Das ist ja fast nix.
51.000 Zeilen.
Und eins davon ist irgendein
SQLite Binary.
Guck mal. 51.000 Codezeilen
für nen MMO Backend.
Wie?
No such file or directory?
So richtig?
Ne, ne, ne.
Da sind Dateien mit Leerzeichen drinnen.
Das stimmt nicht.
Da sind Dateien mit Leerzeichen
Oioioioioi
Clock.
Was? Clock?
Okay. Count lines of code. Alles klar.
Sicher, dass wir das
installieren wollen? Gibt's da nicht irgendwie
was written in Rust?
Placingly fast?
Ach komm, scheiß drauf. Ich kann's ja wieder aninstallen.
Und wie find's das jetzt?
Punkt?
Okay.
Und insgesamt?
432.000
Da auf die C-Sharp-Files kommt's
kommt's an.
432.000
Codezeilen
für nen MMO Backend.
Also.
Ich bleib dabei.
Browser sind heutzutage
die komplexeste Software, die es gibt.
Dann erstmal diesen ganzen Shit wieder
aninstallen. Gibt es nicht?
Muss jetzt gucken, dass ich Clock und nicht
was anderes schreibe.
A fast replay. Written in Rust. Jawoll.
Written in Rust.
Alles written in Rust.
Written in Rust vor 2 Jahren
zuletzt geupdatet. Jawoll.
Gibt's nicht.
Also anscheinend ist so'n komisches Perl-Tool das einzige
im Standard-Library.
Wie findet man da Fehler? Schwierig.
So, was haben wir denn sonst hier?
Genau. Was, was, was ist das?
Was gibt's hier?
Okay.
Ich
würde vermuten,
wenn jetzt
auf der Stelle alle Leute
aus irgendwelchen Gründen verschwinden,
dann ist das ne schwierige Frage.
Erstmal für einen kurzen Moment
läuft alles weiter.
Das ist echt nicht so einfach zu beantworten.
Ich würde mal davon ausgehen,
wir dürfen auf jeden Fall nicht nur
rein an elektrisches
Licht denken.
Was gibt es denn für nicht
elektrische
Lichtquellen, die der Mensch so verwendet?
Na gut.
Aber Kerzen und Dings ist ja noch kürzer.
Keine Ahnung. Gucken wir uns das Video jetzt mal an.
Ja, aber die Sonne zählt nicht.
Ich gehe hier Last Artificial
Light Source.
Also nicht.
Okay.
Unfortunately, although there's enough fuel, most nuclear reactors wouldn't keep running for long.
As soon as something went wrong, the core would go into automatic shutdown.
Every part of a reactor control system is designed so that a failure causes it to rapidly shut down.
This would happen quickly. Many things can trigger a shutdown, but the most likely culprit would be the failure of the power grid.
However, plenty of light comes from sources not tied to the major power grids.
Let's take a look at a few of those and when each one might turn off.
Many remote communities, like those on far-flung islands, get their power from diesel generators.
These can run until their tanks run out of fuel, which in most cases could be anywhere from days to months.
Off-grid generating stations that don't need a human-provided fuel supply would be in better shape.
Geothermal plants can run for a fair bit of time without human intervention.
According to the maintenance schedule for the Svartsengi Island geothermal plant in Iceland,
every six months the operators must change the gearbox oil and re-grease all electric motors and couplings.
Without humans to perform these sorts of maintenance procedures, some plants might run for a few years, but they'd all succumb to corrosion.
Ich überleg gerade.
Es gibt doch so Gartenlichter.
Mit Solarpanels dran.
Die gehen dann halt an mit Bewegungsmelder.
Diese Dinger müssten auch ganz schön lange noch funktionieren.
Ich meine, wir reden jetzt hier nicht von hunderten Jahren oder so.
Das macht die Technik nicht mit.
In Dänemark wurde in den late 1950er-Jahren installiert und es hat für 11 Jahre ohne Maintenanz erzeugt.
Moderne Turbinen sind typisch für drei Jahre ohne Service verwendet und es gibt sicherlich einige, die für Jahrzehnte laufen würden.
Und einer von ihnen hat wahrscheinlich zumindest eine Status-LED irgendwo drin.
Am Ende würden die meisten Windturbinen von der gleichen Sache stoppt, die die geothermische Planeten zerstört würde.
Seine Gears würden aufsteigen.
Generatoren, die Wasser in die Elektrizität verwandeln, werden auch weiter funktionieren.
Ein Operator an der Hoover Dam hat einmal gesagt, dass wenn jeder rausgeht, die Facility für mehrere Jahre auf Autopilot weiter funktionieren würde.
Obwohl, wenn die Druckgröße runtergeht, wird alles weiter funktionieren.
Wenn die Druckgröße runtergeht, wird alles weiter funktionieren.
In der Endzeit würde die Dam wahrscheinlich auf die verhungerten Ausgaben oder die gleiche Art von mechanischer Verletzung auslaufen,
die den Windturbinen und geothermischen Planeten zerstört würde.
Batterie-geleitete Lichter würden nicht viel besser funktionieren und würden alle in ein paar Jahrzehnten ausgehen.
Selbst ohne die Möglichkeit, ihre Kraft zu nutzen, werden Batterien schließlich selbst ausgestattet.
Einige Typen dauern länger als andere, aber auch Batterien, die Advertiser haben, haben lange Schaltzahlen,
die typisch nur eine Jahrzehnte Zeit aufhalten.
Solar Kraft ist wahrscheinlich der am meisten versicherte Kandidat.
Es gibt viele off-grid solar-geleitete Gebäude, Wetterstationen und andere...
Da hab ich, da hab ich wie gesagt, da hab ich auch grad dran gedacht.
Aber ich glaube, das Zeug ist halt auch nicht so super widerstandsfähig.
Das mag, das mag ein paar Jahre halten, vielleicht auch ein paar Jahrzehnte, aber das war's dann.
...herum die Welt.
Ursprüngliche Anrufe, oft auf der Seite der Straße und an remote Locationen, sind oft solargeleitet.
Sie haben normalerweise Lichter an, die jede Nacht Illumination bieten.
Wie Windturbinen sind sie schwer zu servicen und sind also für eine lange Zeit gebaut.
Solar-Panel werden generell so lange dauern, bis die Elektronik mit ihnen verbunden ist
und so lange, bis die Panel frei von Stoff und Dschungel gehalten sind.
Die Widerstände und die Zirkel werden schlussendlich zu Korrosion stürzen,
aber Solar-Panel in einem trockenen Ort mit gut gebauten Elektroniken
könnten in einem Jahrzeitraum weiterhin Kraft bieten, wenn sie frei von Stoff gehalten werden
durch gewöhnliche Winde oder Regen auf den ausgeschlossenen Paneln.
Wenn wir auf eine strikte Definition von Lichtung folgen,
könnten solargeleitete Lichter an remote Locationen
bemerkenswert die letzte lebendige menschliche Lichtquelle sein.
Aber es gibt noch einen anderen Wettbewerber, und das ist ein seltsamer.
Spendende nukleare Energie.
Ja, okay.
Das ist unfair jetzt.
Wenn man das mithält, dann leuchtet das wahrscheinlich für, keine Ahnung,
850.000 Jahre oder so.
Die Sonne leuchtet auch noch lange.
Die Sonne ist immer noch unerhört, wenn sie unerhört ist.
Sobald die phosphoreszente Farbe auslöst,
sind die Schaltdialer immer noch radioaktiv, aber nicht mehr gläubig.
Die Schaltdialer sind aber nicht unsere einzige radioaktive Lichtsource.
Wenn radioaktive Partikel durch Materialien wie Wasser oder Glas fliegen,
emittieren sie Licht durch einen optischen Sonnen-Boom.
Dieses Licht heißt Cherenkov-Radiation
und wird im distinguierten blauen Glow der nuklearen Reaktoren gesehen.
Einige radioaktive Wasteprodukte, wie Cäsium-137,
Ich glaube, man sollte hoffen, dass man nie den blauen Schimmer
um einen Nuklearreaktor selbst sieht, oder?
Das dürfte einem nicht gut kommen, wenn man den sieht.
werden mit Glas vermeltet und vermischt,
was sich in einen sauberen Block befindet,
bevor er in mehr Schaltdialer für Transport und Versorgung befestigt wird.
Und im Dunkeln glößen diese Glas-Blocken blau.
Cäsium-137 hat eine Halbzeit von 30 Jahren,
was bedeutet, dass zwei Jahrhunderte später
die Blocken immer noch mit 1% ihrer originalen Radioaktivität blauen werden.
Da die Farbe des Lichts nur auf die Energie des Partikels abhängt
und nicht auf die Anzahl der Radiation,
wird es in der Zeit breit werden,
aber die gleiche blaue Farbe bleibt.
Und so erreichen wir unsere Antwort.
Jahrhunderte später, tief in Konkretwäldern,
wird das Licht aus unserem am meisten toxischen Wachstum
immer noch blauen.
Das ist der größte, größten, ja,
überwiegende Teil der Welt.
Da gebe ich nicht mehr recht.
Aber hat sehr viele Videos in der Richtung
und ich predikte jetzt einfach mal,
in diesem Video wird er erzählen,
wir gucken es auch nicht ganz an,
ich will einfach nur kurz gucken,
ob ich recht habe,
in diesem Video wird er erzählen,
Samsung hat irgendwas abgeschaltet,
was, ähm, was kann das sein,
was dazu führt, dass man das Gerät nicht mehr richtig benutzen kann
und jetzt ist er, jetzt ist er stinkig.
Ich, ich weiß nicht, sowas ist das.
Samsung hat bestimmt,
okay, ich weiß es,
Samsung hat irgendeinen Cloud-Service abgeschaltet
und jetzt, äh, funktionieren irgendwelche Geräte nicht mehr.
100 pro.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Okay, es ist sowas,
wie ich gesagt habe.
Ja, es ist sowas in der Richtung,
wie ich gesagt habe, okay,
ja, das müssen wir uns in der Tat nicht angucken,
aber ich, ich habe fast vermutet,
dass irgendwas in der Richtung ist.
Er hat schon recht.
Deswegen bin ich auch sehr skeptisch mittlerweile,
was ist das?
Falschschrift-Videos sind immer nice.
Deswegen bin ich auch sehr skeptisch
bei vielen Sachen, die ich kaufe,
gerade wenn es etwas ist,
was ein bisschen teurer ist
und ich eigentlich nicht vorhabe,
mir alle paar Jahre,
was Neues zu kaufen.
Ja, deswegen bin ich da auch immer sehr skeptisch,
wenn da irgendwelche Services
dabei gebundelt sind,
ob die denn so lange halten,
wie ich das benutzen will.
Zum Beispiel,
da habe ich den Verkäufer
von meinem Fiat 500e etwas verwirrt.
Der hat mir erzählt,
ja, und das kann man mit dem Smartphone
auf und zu machen und alles.
Natürlich, ich meine, das ist ein Verkäufer,
der hat mir das Ganze angepriesen,
aber was denn ich wusste,
ich gehe ja nicht
zu irgendeinem Autoladen
und gucke mir dort das erste Mal
das Auto an und lasse mich vollschwallen von dem.
Ich habe mir das natürlich
im Vorfeld alles selbst schon mal angeguckt,
was da Sache ist
und er war da ganz begeistert.
Da kann man die Pärchen mit,
kann man aufschließen, mobil und sonst was.
Ja, leider muss man sich die Sachen noch
in so eine Weise...
Ich finde dieses Konzept ehrlich gesagt auch doof,
dass man in irgendeinen Laden gehen muss,
weil man kann das Auto nicht einfach
bei Fiat online bestellen
und es wird dann zu mir heimgefahren.
Das ist echt letztes Jahr tausend
ganze Sachen mit Autokauf und sowas.
Naja, zumindest hat er sich da überschlagen
mit App und kann man das Fahrzeug
auf und zu schließen
und dann kann man irgendwelche Statistiken sehen
und man kann gucken,
was im Radio dienst.
Man kann pre-heaten das Ganze im Winter
und sowas.
Und da habe ich ihn auch gefragt,
ist das alles sehr nice?
Wer hat da auch ein Video zu?
Das ist ja alles sehr nice,
aber ich frage mich,
ist das an ein Abo gebunden?
Da meinte er so, wie an Abo?
Naja, wie lang geht das Ganze denn?
Also dieser Service?
Das ist ja offensichtlich
ein Webservice.
Ist das an irgendein Abo gebunden?
Und
da war er verwirrt,
da wusste er erst gar nicht, was ich meine.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob er nicht wusste,
ob er absichtlich nicht wissen wollte,
was ich meine.
Und
dann hat er sich dazu hinreißen lassen,
zu sagen, ja das kann man dann immer machen.
Aber ich wusste zu dem Zeitpunkt,
das ist falsch.
Das kann man nicht immer machen.
Das geht glaube ich 2 oder 3 Jahre,
ist das mit dabei.
Und danach muss man dann
keine Ahnung 20 Euro im Jahr
oder so bezahlen, dass das weiterläuft.
Das habe ich mir schon im Vorfeld
angeguckt,
weil mir klar war,
wenn der Autohersteller,
in dem Fall halt Fiat,
nicht nur das Autohaus,
wenn die irgendwelche smarten Funktionen anpreisen,
dann ist das nichts,
was mit dem Kauf
einmalig sich erledigt hat.
Habe ich schon nachgeguckt.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob er es nicht wusste,
oder ob er mir absichtlich Mist erzählt hat.
Eigentlich hätte man sagen müssen,
ist ja geil, das Ding ist gekauft,
aber das mit dem für immer kostenlosen
Online Service, das müssen wir schon
in unseren Vertrag reinschreiben.
Hätte er dann am Ende
nicht gemacht, weil er genau wusste,
oder wenn der Chef sich das nochmal angeguckt hätte,
genau gewusst hätte, ey, das ist nicht...
Aber ich wusste das ja im Vorfeld.
Und ich wollte das Auto ja auch in der Kombination
haben, weil das echt
relativ günstig war.
Das war noch...
Ich habe mir das gekauft...
Habe ich mir das gekauft? 2023?
Nee, doch, doch.
Nee, nee, 2022
habe ich mir das gekauft.
August 2022.
Ja, ja, August 2022
habe ich mir das ganze gekauft.
Ich wusste im Prinzip ja schon, was Sache ist.
Ich habe gesagt, okay,
ich kann auch nach 2-3 Jahren gar nicht 20 Euro
oder sowas im Jahr bezahlen.
Und das war so in der Zeit,
wo sich alle wie verrückt Elektroautos gekauft haben,
um sich auch diese Prämie zu sichern und alles.
Ja.
Und nachdem es ja im Prinzip fast nur die Hälfte gekostet hat,
dadurch, dass das Auto schon ein paar Kilometer
drauf hatte, habe ich gesagt, ey,
gebt her.
Ich nehme das so, wie es ist.
Und ich muss sagen, nach 2 Jahren
jetzt Fiat 500e,
ich finde das immer noch ganz gut.
Elektroauto hat was.
Was ich cool finden würde,
wenn die ganze Elektronik
etwas mehr, etwas offener wäre,
aber das kann man ja prinzipiell vergessen
bei Autoherstellern.
Ich glaube, bei Tesla ist die ganze
Elektronik-Sache, was das angeht, tatsächlich
noch am besten.
Was irgendwelche Modifikationen
und API-Sachen
angeht. Bei Fiat ist es
für den Arsch.
Deswegen habe ich ja den
Fiat Champ programmiert,
um ein paar Sachen von denen abzugreifen,
der natürlich keinerlei
Bugs oder Probleme hat, wie man hier
sieht.
Und der auch seit 2 Jahren schon
top aktuell
und funktioniert.
Kannst du mit deinem Auto ein Fahrrad mitnehmen?
Ja, kann ich, aber nur,
wenn ich eines der beiden
Räder raus mache.
Für komplett reinschieben,
Gachi Bus,
ist das zu klein.
Aber wenn ich vorne das Rad
raus mache, passt das.
Gerade so.
Das ist aber nicht schlimm.
Das Rad vorne rein raus zu machen,
geht in
2 Minuten.
Also bis jetzt hatte ich noch keine Reparaturen.
Wäre ja auch ziemlich kacke.
Ich war jetzt letztes Jahr
und dieses Jahr schon mal da,
zu dieser jährlichen...
Es ist ja entweder jährliche
Wartung oder nach so und so viel Kilometer Wartung.
Ich war zumindest schon zweimal in der Werkstatt.
Hat natürlich auch immer ein bisschen Kohle gekostet,
sonst machen die nix.
Aber war bis jetzt nix.
Und ich hoffe mal, dass auch noch weiter nix ist.
Das wollte ich mir die ganze Zeit schon angucken,
das Video.
Das gucken wir jetzt.
Wir haben uns ein ähnliches Video von dem schon mal angeguckt,
wo er irgendwelche
Bitcoin...
Nee, irgendein...
Irgendein...
So eine Art Yubi-Key
hat er doch mal
geknackt vor ein paar Jahren.
Mit...
Irgendwas, was war das nochmal?
Was wir uns vor ein paar Jahren angeguckt haben.
Das war irgend so ein Hardware-Token.
Was hat er denn da nochmal...
Ich kann mich da gar nicht mehr dran erinnern,
an das alte Video.
Er hat ein Hardware-Token geknackt,
mit...
Mit alter Firmware drauf.
Und das haben sie dann irgendwie ausgetrickst.
Ich kann mich gar nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern.
Zumindest gibt es jetzt was Neues.
Und diesmal geht es wahrscheinlich
um ein...
Bitcoin Software Wallet.
Okay, wahrscheinlich um das Passwort
für das Bitcoin
Wallet.
Dann lasst uns doch mal schauen.
What if I told you?
Frankfurt.
Von der Decke her
sieht das verdächtig nach Frankfurt aus.
Es könnte auch gefühlt
jeder andere Bahnhof sein, der so ähnlich gebaut ist.
Aber das sieht super...
Das auch hier oben.
Das sieht super nach Frankfurt aus, Alter.
That we can hack time.
Mal gucken.
Ah...
Es sieht...
Es sieht schon...
Auf der anderen Seite...
Die Hauptbahnhöfe sehen ähnlich irgendwie aus.
Aber das sieht schon hart
nach Frankfurt aus.
Auch gerade mit diesem,
dass die Züge hier so schräg rein...
Das sieht echt...
To recover over 3 million dollars of Bitcoin
from a software wallet
that's been locked
since 2013.
Das ist Frankfurt. Da oben steht es doch.
Oder? Heißt das Frankfurt?
Frankfurt?
Das ist... Das ist 100% der Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Auch mit den Automaten
hier in der Mitte und so.
Also es gibt bestimmt viele Kopfbahnhöfe, die ähnlich aussehen.
Das ist... Das muss Frankfurt sein, Leute.
Das muss Frankfurt sein.
Aber er hat Glück.
Er ist im Bahnhof.
Die ganzen Assis sind vorm Bahnhof
und um den Bahnhof.
...
I know it sounds crazy.
Ja, das ist 100% pro Frankfurt.
Da hinten war der McDonalds.
But it's true.
I just landed in Frankfurt
Okay, Bestätigung, es ist Frankfurt.
... am able to create another video.
This is a project unlike anything I've worked on before
and I can't wait to share it.
A lot of people have been asking, is Joe Grand still alive?
Yes, I'm still alive.
It's been a really busy year with a lot of projects
and I just haven't really had a lot of time to interact online.
I've been on Zoom calls for hours
talking to people, trying to figure out
if their projects are real.
A lot of times they're not.
Sometimes the value's not there.
This is the money shop, .003 LaVar.
Sometimes we run into really interesting projects
that we can't help with.
There was one guy that actually threw his ledger wallet
into the water for some reason
and it sat submerged for seven months.
He had to hire a dive crew to go down and pick it up
and they sent it to me, opened it up.
Nastiness. Removed all of the corrosion.
Ist schon kacke, ne?
Wenn du dein Token irgendwo in den Fluss schmeißt.
Gibt's ne lustige Geschichte?
Mein Vater
hat nicht sein Bitcoin-Token
in den Fluss geschmissen.
Er hat leider keine Bitcoins gehabt.
Mein Vater hat mal sein Fahrrad
in den Fluss in den Main geschmissen.
Also wenn ich eine Sache
von meinem Vater geerbt hab,
so genetechnisch,
dann ist es, dass ich mich über manche Sachen
spontan recht doll aufregen kann.
Und der muss wohl mal hier in Hanau
oder Frankfurt, weiß ich gar nicht,
ich glaub in Hanau,
über die Brücke gefahren sein mit seinem Fahrrad
und
irgendwas war mit dem Fahrrad.
Wahrscheinlich Kette runtergesprungen,
was auch immer.
Und dann hat er kurz
einen Rage-Moment gehabt
und hat das Fahrrad genommen
und von der Brücke in den Main geschmissen.
Und seit diesem Tag,
also das Fahrrad war natürlich dann weg,
erzählt er mir ab und zu mal
in größeren Abständen,
dass das das beste Fahrrad war,
das er je gehabt hat.
Weil so toll kann es nicht gewesen sein.
Das muss ich mir schon öfter anhören.
Wie echte Leute treffen,
das ist aber nix für mich.
Das muss ich mir schon öfter anhören.
Das ist ein Software-Wallet
mit 1,6 Millionen Dollar.
Und die Geschichte beginnt mit meinem Freund Bruno.
Mittlerweile wahrscheinlich 3 Millionen wert.
Ah ja, hier steht's ja auch.
Hey, ich hab's geschafft. Wie geht's dir?
Schön dich zu sehen.
Ich bin der Ego,
der bei einem meiner vorherigen Videos
mich auf die Hilfe für ein Projekt geholfen hat.
Es scheint, dass Bruno auch Hacker ist
und viel Erfahrung hat mit dem Software-Wallet.
Aber zuerst sollten wir Kaffee trinken.
Wir sind gute Freunde geworden
und haben viel auf interessantes Material zusammengearbeitet.
Bruno ist einer derjenigen,
der einfach nur sehr tief im Kurs ist,
aber wahrscheinlich auch am klugsten.
Er ist als Hacker aufgewachsen
und hat einige lustige Geschichten
darüber gesprochen, was er zu jemals gemacht hatte.
Ich glaube, das war, als ich...
... und wir sind gute Freunde geworden.
Bestimmt Wobblos-Viewer, ja, ganz bestimmt.
Der wirkt so super enthusiastisch und happy, wenn er erzählt.
Bis jetzt war da noch gar nichts.
Wir haben ein paar wirklich interessante Sachen zusammen gemacht.
Bruno ist einer dieser Leute, der wirklich niedrig ist,
aber er ist wahrscheinlich der Smarteste.
Doch, ich meine, er weiß, dass er es geschafft hat
und nimmt das nachträglich auf, höchstwahrscheinlich.
Er ist ein Hacker geworden
und hat einige wirklich lustige Geschichten darüber,
was er gemacht hat, als er alt war.
Ich glaube, das war, als ich zwölf war.
Er hat bestimmt nicht sein Fahrrad von der Brücke geschmissen.
Richtige Hacker-Mens.
... kann gut zusammenarbeiten.
Und wenn du das tust, kann es wirklich großartig sein.
Ich kann nicht warten, um seine Reaktion zu sehen.
Relatable.
Michael hat mich ein bisschen über ein Jahr ago geemailt.
Und er hat im Grunde gesagt,
dass ich ein Passwort habe, das ich auf einer Software-Wallet hatte.
Im Jahr 2013 hat er ein Passwort für diese Wallet
mit einem Passwortgenerator genannt,
das heißt RoboForm.
Das sieht so aus, wie so gefühlt jede Webseite heute aussieht.
Copyright 1999 bis 2024, okay.
I used a program called RoboForm
for managing all my passwords.
I want to make it very secure.
20 signs with special characters.
Password generators are commonly used to create complex passwords
because humans are very predictable
and they'll use the same passwords over and over again.
And that's just not secure.
He said he used a 20-character password
with uppercase and lowercase letters, numbers, special characters.
Das ist ganz schön.
Das ist ganz schön viel.
I generate a password, I copied it,
put it in the passphrase of the wallet
and also in a text file that I then encrypted.
The way he saved the password back then
was by saving it in a TrueCrypt container.
An encrypted partition on his computer.
Ah, okay.
Okay, verstehe.
Das ist quasi überbande, wie man das passt.
Man braucht quasi das Passwort für den TrueCrypt-Container.
Nicht wirklich das...
Im TrueCrypt-Container ist dann quasi eine Textdatei drin
mit dem eigentlichen Passwort.
Aber der TrueCrypt-Container ist verschlüsselt.
Okay, ja.
Im Prinzip macht es relativ wenig Unterschied.
Das ist ganz schön lang.
Das Partition, basically a holder of data,
got corrupted, which caused him to lose his password.
And at this time was like, okay, crap.
A couple of thousand euros, which was painful, but okay.
But then...
That's when we found out, what's the price tag involved.
The Bitcoin price rise and rise.
This crazy amount of money, where it's 43 Bitcoin.
1.6 million.
Oh, I have this fortune.
Das ist schon ein bisschen Folter, oder?
Wenn du weißt, du hast 40 Bitcoin,
du kannst immer nur zugucken, wie das höher steigt,
und du weißt eigentlich,
hättest du, hättest du,
hättest du aufgepasst, jetzt 3 Millionen Euro?
Das grenzt schon echt an Folter, so ein bisschen.
Psychologisch.
I can't use it, because I don't have the password.
Lass uns mal kurz ausrechnen.
Was hat er?
26 mal 2?
So, mindestens das.
Und was hat er dann sonst noch?
Sonderzeichen, gell?
Ach komm, mach mal einfach 60.
60 hoch 20.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Aber, kann das BC ausrechnen?
Ja.
Das ist eine ganz schön große Zahl.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man die nennt,
bei dieser Größe.
Bei mir hört es bei Milliarde auf.
Ich behaupte aber mal,
das ist mehr, als man in irgendeiner Art und Weise
realistisch betrachtet, auch mit Grafikkarten
und whatever, durchprobieren kann.
Also das ist sehr, sehr viel.
He had only seen the actual password
for about 10 seconds.
So he really has no recollection at all
of what that password could actually be.
Then I saw Joe's video, how he hacked the hard wallet
and that gave him confidence.
Maybe these guys have a clue how to help.
I remember my response to him was,
this is not gonna work, unless there's a bug in robo form
that we can take advantage of.
So we turned down the project.
It's a really hard problem to have,
because from bruteforcing it's not possible.
Bruteforcing a password is basically where you generate
a huge list of every...
Also 20 Stellen ist schon nicht ohne.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass 20 Stellen komplett unmöglich...
Ich weiß es nicht, wie es aktuell aussieht,
wenn du wirklich Millionen und fette Ressourcen hast,
bis welche...
Aber 20 erscheint mir ehrlich gesagt zu lang.
Jetzt auch bauchgefühlmäßig würde ich sagen,
ist das zu viel.
Das ist zwar weniger, als es vermutlich Teilchen im Universum gibt,
dass es irgendwas um 10.60 Uhr oder so was,
oder 10.70 Uhr oder 10.80 Uhr oder 10.90 Uhr...
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Es ist nicht komplett unrealistisch viel,
aber es ist...
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass du das sinnvoll bruteforcen kannst.
Zumindest brauchst du mehr Geld,
als das, was in Bitcoins drauf ist dafür.
So viel können wir sicher sein.
Und das ist ein riesiges Problem.
Wenn wir alle möglichen Passwortkombinationen probieren,
ist das mehr als 100 Trillionen Mal
die Anzahl der Wasserdroppen im ganzen Welt.
Ja gut, das sind immer so Vergleiche.
Das bringt keine was.
Das kann man sich nicht vorstellen.
Lass uns mal gucken.
Da gibt es doch so schöne Tabellen zum angucken.
Passwort, Brutforce, Estimated.
Immer so schöne Graphics.
Hier, Graphics von 2023.
Mal gucken, ob das realistisch ist,
was wir da aufgemacht haben.
Also, Numbers only.
Ja gut, Numbers only, das ist schon...
Aber da sieht man schon...
Wisst ihr, was ich cool finde?
An Numbers only,
also wenn du nur 0 bis 9 verwenden kannst,
also wenn du nur 10 verschiedene Zeichen hast,
da sieht man schon,
dass bei jeder Stelle,
das um 1 bis 10,
das um ein Vielfaches,
schwieriger wird.
Ja?
Bis 15 stellen, kein Problem.
Dann dauert das Ganze aber schon eine Stunde.
Dann dauert es 40 Stunden, dann dauert es 6 Tage.
Ja, wahrscheinlich sind wir bei einem Monat
bei 19 und bei, was weiß ich,
über einem Jahr bei 20.
Ja, also das ist schon...
Und sobald noch ein bisschen was an Randomness dazukommt,
das sind nur Lower Case Letters.
Guckt mal, nur Lower Case Letters.
Und da sind wir hier schon bei 18-stelligen Passwörtern
bei 481.000 Jahren.
Was man auch sehr schön an diesen Bildern sieht, ist,
ich habe keine Ahnung,
ob das so wirklich so richtig stimmt,
was sie da in diese Berechnung mit eingebaut haben,
ja, was sie damit...
Letztendlich ist es aber auch bei diesen Zeitskalen relativ egal,
ob man jetzt doppelt so schnell fährt, oder nicht.
Ob jetzt was 480.000 Jahre braucht,
oder 900.000 Jahre, oder 250.000 Jahre,
das ist jetzt nicht so wirklich relevant, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sie es berechnet haben.
Welche Rechenleistung sie der Sache zugrunde legen.
Aber ich finde, man sieht ja sehr schön daran,
dass das Entscheidende bei einem Passwort die Länge ist.
Nicht so sehr,
also die Komplexität,
also nicht so sehr die mögliche Anzahl von Zeichen,
also von einer Stelle,
sondern die Länge ist tatsächlich viel, viel wichtiger,
als so der Zeichenvorrat, den man hat.
Natürlich, das Beste ist eine Kombination aus allem,
also hier Lowercase, Uppercase, Sonderzeichen, Zahlen und lang,
dann wird es halt ein bisschen schwierig zu tippen irgendwann.
Deswegen,
sind ja auch solche Sachen,
wie randomizede Wortlisten und sowas recht beliebt.
Mittlerweile gibt es ja auch sowas mit Fake-Wörtern,
die sich quasi nur anhören, als wären es englische Wörter,
sind aber randomized,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das nennt.
Also es hört sich an wie echte Wörter,
es sind aber eigentlich randomizede Wörter,
die aber aussprechbar randomized wurden.
Das ist dann ganz nice,
da kann man sich 60-stellige Passwörter machen
und sie sind trotzdem noch gut zu tippen
und wenn man ganz gute Wörter hat,
auch halt vielleicht noch ganz gut zu merken.
Ja, aber die Länge ist entscheidend bei einem Passwort.
Nicht so sehr, wie viele Zeichen möglich sind.
Ja, also da wird nichts gebrutforst.
Also er sagt hier, er hat Numbers, Uppercase, Sonderzeichen,
okay, also er hat das hier.
Er sagt, er hat das hier.
Selbst wenn er nur das da hätte, wären 20 Stellen komplett unrealistisch.
Und man sieht auch schon, wie krass das Ganze skaliert.
Das sind die richtigen High-Performer, High-Performance-Mindset-Leute hier.
Guckt euch mal an, wie heftig das skaliert.
Wir reden hier nicht etwa von,
ja, das braucht dann halt mal ein paar Jahre.
Wir reden schon nur bei Lower-Case-Letters und 18 Stellen von über 400.000 Jahren.
Aber das ist nix.
Hier sind wir bei Milliarden, Trillionen Dings.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Bill...
Weiß man ja nie, ob es...
Es sind wahrscheinlich Billion, Milliarden bei uns.
Ja, und das bedeutet,
nur mal so,
dass man das ins Verhältnis setzen kann,
das hier, 48 Milliarden Jahre,
würde es dauern, das Passwort zu knacken.
Das ist länger, als das Universum existiert.
Das ist ein stupides Brutforsten, ja?
Das ist länger, als es das Universum gibt.
Dauert es jetzt nochmal?
Es dauert quasi dreimal das Alter des Universums.
Das ist schon lang.
Okay.
Oh, weiter.
Machen Quantencomputer da einen Unterschied?
Das kommt drauf an,
was da die Grundlage ist.
Ich bin jetzt da bei weitem nicht irgendwie der krasse Checker
und Experte.
Es kommt darauf an,
ob das ein Problem ist,
bei dem Quantencomputer...
Ein Problem ist, wo es sinnvolle Algorithmen
für Quantencomputer gibt,
wo einem ein Quantencomputer was hilft, was bringen würde.
Es gibt auch Probleme,
da bringt dir ein Quantencomputer nichts.
Das kommt tatsächlich auf das jeweilige Problem an.
Ob es dir in diesem Fall was bringen würde?
Keine Ahnung.
Wir dachten,
dass er diese riesige Anzahl von möglichen Passwörtern
brüten muss,
weil er so eine riesige Anzahl von Passwörtern benutzt hat.
Niemand würde ein solches Projekt von dieser Größe
brüten lassen,
egal wie viele Computer sie hatten.
Es ist einfach nicht möglich.
Ich dachte auch schon,
dass ich es meinem Kind weitergeben kann.
Einen Tag kann er...
Das ist ein richtig guter Punkt,
den der Typ da gerade bringt.
Und zwar,
das ist auch eines der Gründe,
warum er nicht alles,
trotz Verschlüsselung,
sinnlos im Internet hochladen sollte.
Weil nur weil etwas heute sicher ist,
bzw. heute keine Schwachstellen bekannt sind,
heißt das lange nicht,
dass das in 20 Jahren immer noch so sein muss.
Und wenn ihr einmal im Internet etwas raufgeladen habt,
müsst ihr potenziell davon ausgehen,
dass es einmal im Internet immer im Internet ist.
Stellt euch mal vor,
ihr ladet jetzt euren Passwortsafe hoch,
verschlüsselt,
bei Google,
zum einfachen Sinken.
Irgendjemand bekommt den in die Finger,
was auch immer,
sei es nur Google selbst.
Jetzt aktuell ist alles sicher,
aber vielleicht ist man in 20 Jahren schlauer.
Vielleicht hat man Sicherheitslücken in AIS gefunden,
was ich mal nicht hoffen will,
dann hätten wir echt Probleme.
Oder andere Sachen.
Aber wenn der Passwortsafe erst gar nicht im Internet ist,
dann gibt es das Problem grundsätzlich nicht.
Da wäre ich jetzt...
Da wäre ich jetzt, als die Roboform erwähnt haben, wäre ich tatsächlich auch von ausgegangen, dass jetzt irgendwas, bestes Pausebild, dass irgendwie sowas in der Richtung kommt. Ich kenne das Programm nicht, aber ich hätte auch vermutet, dass sie irgendwas finden in diesem Programm.
Und nachdem der Titel ist, I hacked time, vermute ich, dass das Ding seine Randomness in irgendeiner Art und Weise aus der Urzeit ableitet, wie auch immer.
In the world of software, and actually the world at large, creating random numbers is very, very hard.
Some people might even say, well, a coin flip is random.
If you know the velocity of the flip, what side of the coin you're starting on, an error.
Ein Coin Flip ist random genug.
Flow and other parameters, you might be able to actually reduce the randomness.
That's kind of what we're doing.
To identify how Roboform creates the password.
If we can manipulate that randomness, we might be able to create a predictable output that we could use to try to crack Michael's wallet.
They ask me now about which version I use.
When I created the password.
He created his wallet in 2013.
After the first payments into the wallet.
So we went through on the Roboform website, looking for what version of that software was available in 2013.
Okay, klingt logisch.
Du musst erst mal wissen, mit was er das generiert hat.
It was pretty cool, where he basically was like, here are the potential versions.
Then we found the changelog of Roboform.
On the Roboform website.
Die haben einen Changelog.
Also ich hätte jetzt mit allem gerechnet, aber nicht, dass Roboform ein öffentliches Changelog hat.
Die haben einen Changelog, der die verschiedenen Veränderungen darstellt, als sie ihre Software über die Zeit verändern.
Das ist der Changelog, der aktuell in Version 9.5.6 ist.
Die Version, die er am 26.06.2013 benutzt hat.
Es gab etwas Interessantes, was wir in diesem Changelog gefunden haben.
Ein paar Jahre später hat ein kleiner Kommentar...
... die Randomität erhöht.
Warum sollte die Randomität erhöht werden, wenn ein Generator eine secure Passwort generiert?
Das bedeutet, dass die früheren Versionen dieses Programms zu jemandem vulnerablen waren.
Vielleicht haben sie das Problem später gelöst, aber es ist so passiert, dass Michael diese früheren Versionen benutzt hat,
wo die Randomität der Passwörter noch nicht gelöst worden ist.
Es ist eine ziemlich verdammt komplizierte Sache, um das zu erklären.
Weißt du, das ist nicht ein normaler Prozess.
Das ist wirklich verrückt.
Ähm, okay.
Ja, ich kann nicht glauben, dass wir das tatsächlich machen werden.
Es ist so...
Es ist eindeutig Frankfurt, Leute.
Ja, ich kann nicht glauben...
Ich bin nicht schon mit dem Fahrrad lang gefahren.
Hier rechts...
Hier rechts das Ding, wo der Willy Brandt platzt.
Ja.
Ich glaube, dass wir das tatsächlich machen werden.
Es ist so verrückt.
Der RoboForm Passwort Generator ist ein ziemlich großes Stück Software.
Aber innerhalb dieses großen Programms wollen wir versuchen, das eine Stück Code zu finden,
wo die Passwort-Generation stattfindet.
Mal sehen, ob wir etwas Code schaffen können, um direkt dazu zu kommunizieren, um die Passwörter zu generieren, die wir brauchen.
Dann jetzt erstmal...
Dann jetzt erstmal good luck.
Decompilen, disassemblen und...
...
RoboForm Software is known as what's called closed source.
This basically is a black box.
Like, you don't know what's going on inside.
That's why we need to use a lot of these software reverse engineering tools to even peek inside.
We started to reverse engineer the software.
The first step was to understand if the generated password from the graphical user interface was stored somewhere in memory.
Hätte man nicht...
Ich meine, ohne Scheiß.
RoboForm.
Das sieht jetzt...
Das sieht jetzt nicht so aus, wie irgendwie eine super...
...
Große, bekannte Firma, die im Geld schwimmt.
Vielleicht tue ich denen Unrecht.
Hätte man denen nicht sagen können, ey.
Wir haben hier einen Bitcoin Wallet mit 3 Millionen drauf und mit 1,6 Millionen drauf.
Wir geben euch 100...
Wir geben euch 100k ab.
Wenn ihr uns erzählt, was...
...
Wenn das dazu führt, dass wir das knacken können.
Ich meine, auf der anderen Seite müssten die dann quasi zugeben, dass ihre alte Software nicht so gut war.
Das ist vielleicht auch nicht so geil.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, ich kann das nachvollziehen, dass man das nicht machen möchte, weil das selbst rausbekommen ist natürlich deutlich nicer.
Das ist das, wo die Leute früher in solitär immer gecheatet haben.
Und sich krass Hackermans gefühlt haben.
Leute, die haben das doch ganz normal im Keller gehackermant und das Video haben die dann nachgedreht, oder?
Die sind doch nicht während das lief irgendwie am Main spazieren gegangen, haben darüber geredet und so.
Ja.
Was? Jetzt habe ich nicht aufgepasst.
Ah.
Das hat mein, also, Ghidra bringt meinen Kopf komplett zum, zum, zum Exploden.
Ja.
Ja, von, von dem es meint, dass das besser lesbar ist.
Wisst ihr, was ich an dem Video gut finde?
Dass es nicht so ein typisches Hackerman Bullshit Video ist, wo sie, wo sie so ultra um heißen Brei rumreden und dann so auf, jetzt wird das aber ernst.
Und so was machen, sondern dass man sieht, dass das, dass er so, dass er sehr viel Arbeit und Hirnschmalz reinfließt in sowas und dass es nicht einfach auch nur gelaber ist, sondern dass sie wissen, was sie treiben.
Well, view, but it's still really.
Keine Mainstream Hackerman Video würde man hier sowas.
Sogar mit Namens Erwähnung, das im Leben nicht.
You have a higher level human readable view, but it's still really difficult, especially if you have a really complex.
So this is a massive amount of code, hours and hours and hours of work.
We're definitely on the right track.
Now we're seeing references to a password generator within this code.
We were able to actually narrow down where the password generator function was.
Number of characters for your password length.
The minimum number of digits sounds like a password generator to me.
This seems to be the candidate for the actual password generator routine.
Kita macht ich, ich check, ich check null da drin.
Es ist nicht so, als hätte ich es nicht schon geöffnet.
Ist auch nicht so, als hätte ich da schon mal ein paar Mal drin rumgeklickt und versucht, irgendwas zu finden.
Das macht mein Hirn nicht.
Also Hut ab für alle, die da durchblicken.
One of the pieces of the code that we found was really interesting is this reference to calling the system time.
A reference in the assembly language.
You can actually see that after it calls the time, it does some manipulation to that time value.
Was sehen wir denn da?
You can actually see that after it calls the time, it does some manipulation.
Wir sehen time in seconds, time 64.
Das ist der Datentyp.
Okay.
Zeug.
Ah, wahrscheinlich Nullpointer.
Wenn man da Nullpointer reinsteckt in time 64, dann bekommt man die time in seconds.
Hä?
Okay.
Irgendwelche Bild-In-Sachen.
Das ist quasi time now oder sowas.
So.
Dann gibt es time in seconds reduced.
Time in seconds right shift.
Das kriege ich jetzt im Kopf aber nicht hin.
Was?
Das kann doch alles passieren.
Okay.
Dann wird randomized time in seconds minus irgendein Ding.
Ja gut, der Rest ist der Rest.
Wo schreibt denn der den Output hin von random?
Der ruft srand auf und was passiert mit dem Output?
Den gibt es nicht, oder?
Relation to that time value.
And then it calls the function that initializes pseudo random number generator with some seed value.
Das ist der Seed.
Okay, da haben sie es natürlich verkackt, die Roboform, Leute.
That's what we were looking for.
That's the key to this whole thing.
If we can change the system time, that might mean that we can actually control what the output passwords are.
Ich habe sowas, als ich den Titel gesehen habe, habe ich mir genau sowas, nicht exakt sowas, aber sowas in der Richtung schon gedacht.
Dynamic analysis.
In a perfect world, when you generate a password.
With a password generator, you expect to get a unique, random output each time that no one else has.
In this version of Roboform, that's not the case.
While Roboform passwords appear to be...
Gut, jetzt musste im Prinzip einfach nur so, weiß nicht, ob man das genau festmachen kann, wann er das generated hat.
Das kann man doch bestimmt nachbauen, oder?
Da braucht man doch bestimmt Roboform gar nicht mehr.
Man kann doch diese Routine zum Passwort...
generieren, sicherlich easy nachbauen.
Ich gehe davon aus, die werden das Ding jetzt einfach nachbauen und dann sRent quasi mit allen möglichen Werten füttern, die innerhalb von einem Jahr oder so, wo das generiert wurde, und dann kriegst du dann eine Passwortliste mit, keine Ahnung, paar Millionen Passwörtern drinne, und die probierst du durch.
Das ist innerhalb von ein paar Sekunden.
...passiert.
...be randomly generated, they're not.
With the older versions of this software, if we can control the time, we can control the password.
Imagine that these cars represent my password.
And every time I snap my fingers, I can generate a new password.
If I wanted to control what my password would be, I could control the cars to give a predictable result.
We can do the same thing to control Roboform to get a predictable password.
Good luck.
Wir haben es uns doch jetzt nicht einfach in Frankfurt auf die Gast gestellt.
...gut, we can control the time, we can control the password.
Da hat er aber nicht die Rechnung gemacht mit irgendwelchen Berufsverkehr-Rage-Leuten.
Okay, ja, er hat sich nicht angeklebt, stimmt.
Okay, ja, er hat sich nicht angeklebt.
Ich hab so keine Ahnung von Debuggern auf Windows.
Alter, dieser Stream ist das Sprint-Review.
Erzähl doch mal, was du letzten Sprint-Nices umgesetzt hast.
Phase Run.
Ganz essentiell, dass man sich auf den Zettel schreibt.
Das wäre nicht anders gegangen.
ZBM.
Let's generate a new password on the screen.
Now the EAX value has changed, because time has increased since the last time I generated the password.
But this is where I can actually patch the memory and hack the time.
Double-click on EAX and change that value to the one that we've recorded.
Previously.
Die Sieden des Random jedes Mal?
Bei jedem Aufruf davon?
Ich hätte jetzt eher gedacht, die Sieden das halt einmal.
Ich meine, so ist besser.
So ist viel besser für die, wenn ich so mal, also zum rausbekommen ist das für die besser, ja.
Andersrum wäre es ein bisschen problematischer gewesen, wenn das quasi den Sied nur einmal beim Starten setzt.
Da müsstest du dann quasi für jede, keine Ahnung, jede Millisekunde?
Oder sowas?
An dem Tag müsstest du dann, ja, keine Ahnung, zwei, drei, zwei, drei Tage Passwörter generieren.
Aber das wäre immer noch alles im Rahmen gewesen, wäre auch deutlich aufwendiger, als die ursprüngliche Passwortanzahl Putforsen.
Nee, der Fix war, wisst ihr, was der richtige Fix für sowas ist?
Gar keine Zeit nehmen als Random Seed, sondern irgendeine...
Eine Random Source von einer CPU.
Oder irgendeine Random Source, die der NOS bereitstellt.
Aber am besten ist, oder Mausmove nimmt, ja.
Aber es gibt mittlerweile ja in den gängigen CPUs halbwegs brauchbare Random Rauschquellen, ja.
Also du kannst bei aktuellen Intel und AMD CPUs kannst du mit dem passenden Befehl kannst du dir Random...
...Number erzeugen lassen.
Random Source Intel, irgendwie sowas.
Read Random, sowas, sowas in der Richtung.
Das kannst du bei Intel machen, kannst du bei AMD machen.
Da kriegst du eine Random...
Das ist dann...
Da bin ich jetzt aber wirklich nicht groß knowledgeable drinne.
Ja, unter Linux kannst du sowas machen.
Das ist aber dann glaube ich nicht so schnell.
Aber das ist quasi dann die echteste Random Quelle, die du so hast.
Im Computer.
Und das kannst du dann als Seed nehmen für einen ordentlichen Random Number Generator.
Der ist dann schneller.
Und du hast trotzdem ein Random Seed.
Ja, das...
Das hab ich auch schon.
Das hab ich auch schon gehört.
Es gibt ja noch...
Es gibt ja die verrücktesten Varianten von Atmosphärenrauschen und...
Die ollen...
Die analogen Fernsehsignale hatten ja auch viel...
Es gibt ganz viele verschiedene Sachen, um...
Ich weiß nicht, auf was die zurückgreifen, wenn man random ausliest in der CPU.
Keine Ahnung, auf was das passiert.
Ja.
Also...
Die...
So Sachen wie Veracrypt zum Beispiel.
Die nehmen Inputs und Mouse-Movements und sowas.
Ja.
Also mit der Uhrzeit...
Mit der Uhrzeit Seeden ist eigentlich immer eine doofe Idee.
Also, nein, das stimmt nicht.
Es ist nicht immer eine doofe Idee.
Random Seeden...
Uhrzeit Seed ist vollkommen okay, wenn es hier nicht um irgendwelche kryptografischen Sachen geht, die sicher sein müssen.
Ja.
Wenn ich für irgendein Game einen Zufallsteilengenerator Seeden möchte,
ja, das aus meinem Save-File,
wenn ich das Spiel lade,
dass es dann auch immer wieder das Gleiche rauskommt,
das ist vollkommen okay.
Genau.
Kommt drauf an, für was man den braucht.
Wenn das natürlich für sowas ist,
dann ist es blöd, das Ganze mit der Uhrzeit zu Seeden.
Und vor allem auch jedes Mal neu beim Aufruf.
Das ist wirklich fast schon fahrlässig, so ein Ding dann zu vertreiben.
Warum hat es sich eigentlich durchgesetzt?
Ich...
Mag jetzt die übelste Loop-Frage sein.
Aber...
Warum landet so gut wie alles standardmäßig im EAX-Register?
Das ist so das 0815-Register, wo alles irgendwie drinnen landet.
Liegt das vielleicht daran, dass die ersten paar CPUs das unter anderem schon hatten?
Also EAX ist das Standard-Ding.
Egal was du machst, es ist immer EAX.
Allzweckregister.
Vielleicht gab es das schon immer.
Ich meine, so eine aktuelle CPU hat noch deutlich mehr.
Also ein Register, um es mal allgemein zu erklären,
ist quasi der RAM innerhalb einer CPU.
Also quasi der schnellste Speicher, den du im Rechner hast.
Der ist dann auch nicht sonderlich groß.
Also das, was eine CPU sich quasi merken kann.
Und was du für Operationen brauchst.
Also alles, was du in eine CPU übergeben möchtest, was es braucht,
um seine Arbeit zu erledigen, musst du in irgendwelche Register erstmal packen.
Auch unter der Haube, wenn du irgendwie einen Funktionsaufruf machst in der Programmiersprache,
der schön abstrakt aussieht, unter der Haube sind es dann immer irgendwelche
Read-from-Speicher-Adresse-Push-in-XY-Register.
Lässt von Speicheradresse, pusht es da rein.
Deswegen...
Was kannst du über 64-Bit-Speicher-Eingänge sagen?
Hä?
Ähm...
Deswegen...
Ne, das ist nicht der L1- und der L3-Cache.
Das landet danach im L1- und L3-Cache sowas.
Ähm...
Das ist wirklich der Speicher, mit dem die CPU arbeitet, wenn sie Sachen ausführt.
Und...
Da gibt es ganz verrückte Optimierungsmöglichkeiten, ja?
So nach dem Motto, ähm...
Wir vermeiden das jetzt, dass das da rausfliegt.
Also da kann man auf Low-Level-Ebene extrem viel optimieren.
Ne, wie gesagt.
Nicht, dass ich da super viel Erfahrung drin hätte.
Weil unter der Haube ist es ja nicht so, dass eine CPU jetzt das ausführt, was in eurem Source-Code drin steht.
So nach dem Motto, wir rufen jetzt die Funktion Console.WriteLine mit Argument sowieso und sowieso auf.
Unter der Haube wird das in, ja...
Wahrscheinlich 12, 13, 14, 15 CPU-Instruktionen übersetzt, die die CPU dann ausführt.
Und diese Instruktionen, wenn die Parameter brauchen, dass die CPU damit was machen kann.
Ja, zum Beispiel multiplizieren oder addieren.
Dann hast du eine Instruktion fürs Addieren und du musst der CPU sagen, ähm...
Deine, in welchem Register deine beiden Zahlen liegen, die du addieren willst.
Und irgendwo musst du das Ergebnis hin.
Und das kann halt eine CPU relativ schnell machen.
Ja, wenn du, wenn du was, ähm...
Multiplizieren musst, dann würdest du, würdest du bei der CPU schreiben.
Ähm, erstens mal lädst du aus dem RAM irgendeine Zahl, die movst du in ein Register.
Dann lädst du aus dem RAM noch eine andere Zahl, die movst du auch in irgendein Register.
Und dann sagst du deiner CPU, addiere...
Oder Register, Register das und das Register, diese zwei Register zusammen.
Und das Ergebnis landet dann, glaube ich...
Immer im EAX-Register bei den meisten Standardbefehlen.
Oder bei den meisten Standardinstruktionen.
Ich glaube, EAX ist so dieses Allzweck-Output-Register, wo irgendwie alles immer als Ergebnis reinkommt.
Wie gesagt, ich habe von so ultra-low-level Sachen jetzt auch nicht viel praktische Erfahrung.
Ja, aber wenn man guckt...
Wie sowas, wie sowas hier für eine CPU aussieht.
Hier, add to numbers in assembly.
Ja, guckt genau.
Da hast du dann solche Dinger.
Äh, 14 ins EAX-Register moven.
10 ins EBX-Register moven.
Dann der CPU sagen, addiere EAX und EBX-Register.
Der Output landet wiederum in EAX.
So, und was ist das?
Ja, okay, und hier wird printf aufgerufen.
Und hier wird es wieder in RAM geschrieben oder sowas.
Keine Ahnung.
So, jetzt gucken wir aber mal.
Fertig.
Und hier ist es.
Also, wir haben beinahe beurteilt, dass wir die gleiche Passwort generieren können,
mehrere Mal im RAM.
Mit einem Passwortgenerator, der random Passwörter generiert,
sollten wir nicht so etwas machen können.
Das war der erste Moment, in dem wir wussten, dass es eine gute Chance gibt,
Die haben es richtig verkackt, die Programmierer von RoboForm.
und seine Passwörter generieren können.
So können wir eigentlich gehen und das System tricken,
indem wir denken, dass wir zurück in 2013 sind
und alle möglichen Passwörter in diesem Zeitraum generieren können,
in dem wir dachten, dass Michael seine Passwörter generiert hat.
Wir dachten, wir wären gut gegangen.
Wir dachten, dass das Rest smooth sailing wäre.
All we had to do is write some code to control that.
Natürlich funktioniert das nicht, weil das Video geht noch eine Weile.
But yeah, we were wrong.
Be on the lookout for frankfurters.
I bet you that place sells them.
We're gonna see if they have a vegan one.
Do you have any vegan frankfurters?
No.
Thank you.
No visit to Frankfurt would be complete without a frankfurter.
Das ist? Wo sind denn die?
Thank you.
Ist das...
Ist das da, wo sonst der Weihnachtsmarkt ist?
Das ist halt schwer zu sehen.
...be complete without a frankfurter.
So the next step was to write this wrapper code.
...build a code around this certain function.
...to basically let us control the password generator function.
Take this frankfurter for example.
If this is the entire RoboForm program,
the password generator is just a small portion of that.
So we wrote some code to wrap around that function to control it.
Kind of like how this bun wraps around a frankfurter.
Yep, yep, clock.
This is the code that does it all.
Michael changes the system time
and saves the output every single second.
Michael gave us a date range of when he thought he
generated his password.
These are the dates of the range we generated the password.
And that ends up being, like, millions
of potential passwords.
There is always the possibility
that this whole thing isn't possible.
We're gonna need to generate way more passwords
to effectively check the entire timeframe.
This is the wrapper, like, this assembly language
really is the wrapper code.
But then things started crashing. We were just getting crash after crash
Und wieder zu erschöpfen.
Deswegen habe ich eigentlich gedacht,
die bauen das nach und müssen jetzt nicht Roboform rappen.
Jetzt könnte man sagen, mit Rust wäre das nicht passiert.
Aber wäre in dem Fall vollkommen verkehrt.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht,
die extrahieren sich die Logik irgendwie aus Roboform,
sodass sie Roboform selbst nicht mehr brauchen.
Und rufen das dann mit allen möglichen Inputs auf.
Ja kein Wunder, das ist auch C++. Habt ihr es gesehen? Da wundert mich nichts mehr. Nicht
mehr. Ja, das verstehe ich. Ich kann bei, also bei sowas nicht, aber ich kann, wenn ich mich in
irgendwas reingehängt habe, kann ich auch nicht aufhören. Ich kann vielleicht mal kurz pennen
gehen dazwischen am Anundrach, muss ich weitermachen.
Ist jetzt aber ganz schön langsam, oder? Warum ist das so langsam? Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich
gedacht, dass mit Zeitaufrufen, das flutscht jetzt sowas von durch. Sieht man irgendwo,
was sie da gebaut haben eigentlich jetzt? Nee, oder? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Parallelisieren ist
natürlich schwierig, aber.
Ähm, kann das sein? Äh, macht eigentlich keinen Sinn. Keine Ahnung.
Sah man irgendwo was? Hat man irgendwo, irgendwo was gesehen, was sie da programmiert haben?
Würde mich jetzt echt interessieren.
Nee, so, selbst die Konsolausgabe ist nicht so langsam.
Hat man da irgendwas gesehen? Jetzt hier ist die Wurscht. Ja, hier ist die Wurscht. Ach,
hier sieht man doch was, guck mal. Hier sieht man doch was.
Check find the C++
correlation
fragt rainer
Wow.
Moment
What, what, what?
Okay, Windows Geschiess. Ja, hier sieht man, jetzt ehrlich gesagt, nicht so viel. Außer, dass das C++ Congratulations ist, VW sagt, es ist wie in denystem.
Ja, hier sieht man jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so viel.
Außer, dass es Z++ ist, dann ist es zu weit weg.
C++ ist. Cringe.
Aber für sowas ist
wahrscheinlich C++ echt noch
eines der besten Sachen.
Ach, die
setzen jedes Mal die
Windows-Zeit, bevor das
ausgeführt wird. Ja, jetzt verstehe ich
auch, warum das so langsam ist.
Ich dachte, die
pushen einfach quasi als Parameter
und die skippen diesen Step
einfach und pushen quasi
als Parameter
den Timestamp
da rein, in diese Function.
Wobei ich es nachvollziehen
kann, dass man es so macht.
Das ist deutlich geringerer Implementationsaufwand.
Da kannst du dich darauf erinnern, dass es
funktioniert halt einfach. Es liest die
Systemzeit aus.
Es liest die Systemzeit aus. Du musst da nichts drumherum
machen. Musst dich irgendwie in die Parameter patchen
oder sonst was. Ja.
Und es ist wahrscheinlich schnell genug für das, was man
vorhat. Okay, jetzt
verstehe ich aber auch, warum das so langsam ist.
Weil die wirklich die Windows-Zeit
ändern, dann die Funktion laufen
lassen und dann wieder die Windows-Zeit
ändern. Deswegen kannst du auch nichts
parallelisieren. Wenn das Programm
die Windows-Zeit nimmt und keinen Parameter,
du hast recht, dann hast du gelitten. Ja.
Da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht.
Da müsstest du den Funktionsaufruf
irgendwie patchen oder sowas.
Das willst du dann nicht machen. Dann verschiebt sich ja auch
irgendwelche Offsets und
ne. Okay, dann
leuchtet es zwei Sachen. Es leuchtet ein,
warum sie es so gemacht haben.
Und es leuchtet auch ein, dass
es so langsam ist. Dankeschön.
Anonymous Gifter
für den Sub.
Okay, das ist es.
Jetzt ergibt das Sinn.
Okay, da hört es jetzt bei mir
auf.
Minimum Chars
wird in EBX gemovt.
Okay.
Dann wird gesagt, Push EBX.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das macht.
Übelster Kack-Noob.
Ich weiß, aber keine Ahnung.
Dann wird 1 abgezogen
von EBX.
Was macht Push?
Ah. Okay.
Das brauchen die,
dass die Funktion
mit den richtigen Parametern
aufgerufen wird.
Da müsste man sich jetzt mal angucken. Standard C
Function Calling Convention,
wie auch immer.
Das ist quasi das Übergeben
an die Funktion,
dass das an der richtigen Stelle steht.
Okay.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Assembly-Zeug.
Genau. Und hier, Call.
Hier wird die Funktion aufgerufen.
Und das vorher muss gemacht werden,
damit die Funktion die richtigen Parameter
an der richtigen Stelle stehen hat.
Konnten die den Algorithmus von RoboForm
nicht nachbauen? Ich gehe mal davon aus,
die mussten so ein bisschen Trade-Off machen
aus, wie aufwendig wird das Ganze
und wie schnell sind wir mit dem
anderen fertig.
Und das ist schon irgendwie verständlich,
je nachdem, was da drumherum dranhängt.
Ja, ich hätte auch gedacht, dass es einfacher ist,
aber ich gehe mal davon aus, die haben sich ja schon genau angeguckt.
Wahrscheinlich hängt da noch ein bisschen mehr drumherum dran.
Und die rufen
die Originalfunktion auf.
Ja, und die Funktion braucht so Sachen wie,
jetzt verstehe ich auch,
Mindestcharacter,
die gesetzt sind,
für was es, also, wie lang soll
das Passwort mindestens sein? Wie lang soll das Passwort,
Maximum sein? Und
das sind Parameter,
die die Funktion braucht.
Und am Ende steht dann in EAX
das Passwort drin.
Wissen die denn, was RoboForm mit der
Windows-Zeit alles anstellt? Ich glaube, das
haben sie da nicht genau im Detail analysiert.
Die haben rausbekommen,
das benutzt quasi als Grundlage
die Windows,
die Windows-Zeit und danach, gehe ich mal
davon aus, haben sie sich gedacht, ey, warum soll
man das jetzt weiter reverse-engineeren und irgendwie
nachbauen, wenn wir es doch einfach
in halbwegs überschaubarer
Zeit so füttern können?
Klingt alles nachvollziehbar.
All day.
We had this late-night session.
Now it's like two in the morning.
It was killing me to know that we were that close.
My notes from last night and today.
He continued working on it.
Things that were crashing and trying to figure out why it was crashing.
Hours and hours and hours.
Of debugging.
We were so close, but it just wasn't working.
But I just couldn't,
I couldn't help myself.
Ja, das verstehe ich.
Das verstehe ich.
The next day he sent me a message that
guys, I did it.
I cracked the code.
We eventually realized that we had to set certain memory locations
to other values before we called that function.
You can now generate your whole
time span of passwords.
Now we can actually run this code and let it start generating
passwords.
Here we go. Generating.
About 100 passwords per second.
We can actually see down at the bottom of the screen,
our time is increasing.
It's just so satisfying.
It's like we're traveling through time.
I know it's like it sounds super cheesy, but it is really fun.
So we basically generated the millions of passwords for that date range.
He sent those over.
He put it into his password cracking tool.
And we got nothing.
Ja, das Video dauert noch ein bisschen.
Das hätte... Das hätte mich auch gewundert.
Das hätt schon funktioniert.
Was?
Pass auf, am Ende machen die jetzt doch das, was ich von Anfang an vermutet habe, dass
sie das nachbauen, was RoboForm macht.
Dass sie sich jetzt doch genau angucken, wie generiert RoboForm eigentlich das Passwort
und bauen das nach.
Und dann, bam, drei Sekunden geknackt.
Vielleicht, nee, egal, stimmt nicht, was ich sagen wollte.
Genau.
Genau, Plot Twist.
Ihm fällt das Passwort wieder ein.
Das ist das Passwort für den TrueCrypt-Container.
Was sie suchen.
Ring.
And I was like, oh, f***, this can't be happening.
Michael had sent us a list of passwords that he had generated with RoboForm for other things.
But there was just one that was 20 characters in length that was just numbers and letters.
No special characters.
But he had told us that he had used 20 signs with special characters.
So we decided, well, hey, let's just try this new range of passwords using these different
parameters.
Generated those, sent them to Bruno.
Was?
Wie different parameters?
Ich denke, das ist das gleiche wie vorher.
Ja.
Was ist jetzt der Unterschied?
But he had told us that he had used 20 signs with special characters.
So we decided, well, hey, let's just try this new range of passwords.
Hä, das ist doch das gleiche, was die Ursprünglich auch schon mal probiert haben.
Was ist jetzt anders?
Generated those, sent them to Bruno.
Ach, ohne Sonderzeichen, aber die haben doch gerade das Häkchen bei Sonderzeichen gemacht.
Started the script.
Die haben doch gerade das Häkchen bei Sonderzeichen hier gezeigt.
Ach, die haben das weggezogen.
Wie?
weg ach das hat er weg gemacht ok ok video fast fertig jetzt klappt's
ich würde sagen wisst ihr was ich cool finde das video versprüht doch in gewisser
weise sehr viel positive energie
ok
nice
moment hat der ein fiat
fiat enjoyer moment
nee
kein fiat enjoyer
nice view
we're off
I don't know
there are plenty of
items
ideas that you can have
an hour and
an hour and ten minutes
so this size is ok
it's good enough
we did it
checked
I hope it's doing ok down there
if I want to make fun of myself
I tell the story
everyone in my family
every close friend knows it
we're on la Rambla
the most famous street in Barcelona
pardon
ja
in the end
das ist nicht mutig damit rumzulaufen
weil das Ding an sich ist ja nix wert
das ist einfach nur ein Zettel
es ist eine lustige Geschichte
wobei Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof
da weiß man nicht ob die Leute schlau genug sind das zu realisieren
wobei Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof da weiß man nicht ob die Leute schlau genug sind das zu realisieren
I can solve it
wait a minute
da hat jetzt die ganze Zeit in Spanien auf dem Stuhl gehockt
bis sie zufälligerweise reinkommen und sagen passt so
I hope one day
I can solve it
oh my god
surprise
1,6 Billion dollars
der kann sich freuen
auf einen schlag erst mal Millionär
graz
oh ugru
It's not official till we sign the check
this project was really special
to be able to work with de ve to have so much fun
1,6 Billon
1,6 Million
achieving this goal together
I'm going to keep working with different hacking projects
thank you guys
I run
I'm going to continue to help people recover crypto currency
Da hätte ich es richtig verkackt, weil ich gehe davon aus,
dass das, was ich zum Passwort generieren verwende, die Probleme nicht hat.
Wobei ich das Problem nicht hätte.
Ich würde es nämlich mit KeePass generieren und in KeePass speichern
und auch in KeePass backuppen und ich hätte das Problem wahrscheinlich nicht.
Was sie wohl bekommen haben?
Keine Ahnung.
Das war ein nices Video.
Rein von Luft und Liebe, wie man so früher so gesagt hat, kann man ja auch nicht leben.
Ich denke mal schon, dass sie da ein bisschen was davon gehabt haben.
Werden.
Credo, danke schön für den Sub.
Das stimmt.
Wobei er das ganze 2013 generiert hat.
Das ist 10 Jahre her.
So ein Post-it ist halt auch mal schnell weg.
Aber mal Spaß beiseite.
Die Idee, sich Passwörter auf ein Post-it zu schreiben, ist gar nicht mal so blöd.
Weil Post-its haben einen großen Vorteil im Vergleich zu Passwort-TXT auf dem Desktop.
Wenn irgendjemand bei euch auf dem Rechner,
was einschleust, kann er zwar bei euch auf dem Rechner rumgucken und Sachen abgreifen,
aber er kann nicht bei euch auf das Post-it gucken, was am Monitor hängt.
Weil wenn ein Keylogger drauf ist und ihr das eintippt, habt ihr eh verloren.
Wenn er nach Einloggen die Session-Cookies abgreift, habt ihr auch verloren.
Mit Webcam und Spiegel.
Ja klar.
Drohne fernsteuern mit Spiegel dann um die Ecke zu gucken mit der Webcam.
Aber ihr versteht den Punkt.
Manchmal ist so eine Digital-Analog-Barriere gar nicht so einfach zu überwinden.
Die Spiegelung in den Augen, so wie ich mich früher in der Peking-Suppe gespiegelt habe.
Dann ist eh alles vorbei.
So, Package-Updates schnell machen, falls es wieder neue gibt.
Leute, ich habe vor 2 Stunden 40 Minuten Package-Updates gemacht.
Arch, by the way, die nächsten Package-Updates sind am Start.
Nice.
Gut, 22 Uhr.
Wisst ihr, was ich jetzt mache, Leute?
Ihr kommt nie drauf.
Musst du nicht Packman, doch?
Ich habe doch gerade ein Package-Update gemacht.
Falls ich irgendwas übersehen habe, Leute, schreibt es in den nächsten Stream nochmal in den Chat.
Ich habe nicht so viel Chat gelesen gerade in den letzten 1,5 Stunden.
Falls ich irgendwas übersehen habe, merkt es euch.
Gucken wir uns das nächste Mal an.
Oder besprechen wir das nächste Mal.
Bis jetzt ist Z-Server noch das gleiche Problem wie vorher.
Also kann man gerade nicht machen.
Mit Leaks im Stream.
Alles klar, bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.